Why did I put 6pm? I don't even recall. Anyways, surprise, it me. I'm here. 50 hours early.
Is it even working? Hilar? What am I streaming to? Is there a lag? Oh my god. Okay. There
isn't. Sick. I just took a bazillion years. Anyways. Forever streaming. I just never
stop. Never stop streaming. It's only me, myself, and I in the chat right now. Nobody knows I'm here.
Nobody knows what's going to occur. Nobody knows that I'm streaming like three hours in advance.
Two hours in advance. Nobody knows. Oh, I've been had. They've spotted me. Maybe I should
until 6pm. Dabumi? What are you doing? Are you having fun, sir? Sorry for the noise.
Deceiver! Deceiver! I just want to stream. I can't stay away. I don't know what to eat.
I just want to stream. It's all I want to do in life is stream. I don't want to stop.
Let's see how long my internet lasts. Her head's not attached to her body again. Don't
look at that. Don't look at that. You didn't see anything. I'm holding a controller? Yes.
Today's been an interesting day. I woke up,
and that's it. That's it. I didn't do anything else before this. Nothing happened.
I definitely didn't play Elden Ring for three hours. I definitely didn't eat crab, do a mukbang
stream. I definitely didn't make some comments that I had no reason to make comments about because
I had nothing to do with me. But that's just me in general. But those things never happened.
I don't know if some of you guys are delusional. If you think stuff happened,
it did not. I didn't spike my controller several times. I didn't smash something.
I didn't punch a plushie for like two minutes straight. That never happened. I have done
absolutely nothing before this stream besides be cute and hang out with my cats and watch Elden
Ring lore videos. That's all I've been doing this entire time. All I've been doing. But I'll tweet
that I'm live now. I will tweet that I'm live now. I won't lie to you. I thought I was streaming at
four, but I don't. Maybe I put myself at six because I know Amy is strong and you're streaming.
I didn't forgot. Again, I just I got distracted and I was like, oh, I need to stream. And then I'm
like, wait, I already, you guys know how scatterbrained I am. Yeah, nothing, nothing. Yeah, I apologize
for the overlap. I just forget the times I stream at sometimes and when I change it for my normal
time. So we can't do that too for a bit. Because I feel bad if people were like, okay, I'm gonna
make time at six p.m. Eastern to make sure I can watch madam. And then I'm just not there.
Or I'm still streaming at that time for like five hours. I miss Endurance thing. Follow New Vegas.
And we'll we'll see. I've never played a follow game for my life.
Except for like that one like material management thing. Let me post the thumbnail.
Here it is. Such a goofy thumbnail management made for me. Hi, I'm live early because I
forgot that I said I would stream at six p.m. Eastern time. I don't remember my own schedule.
But hi, I'm sorry. Let me just copy that video link real quick like
add tweet and post all. I'm alive now. Hi there. Yeah, I didn't stream at all. I kind of missed you
guys this morning. I wanted I wanted to stream when I wasn't able to really stinks. I don't know.
I don't know. I was like blanked out from this morning. I just remember watching Elmer and
War videos. It's not a recall. My cats are playing in the background. It's mostly Bumi.
It's really just Bumi. He's breakdancing on a piece of cardboard where they're left on the floor.
I came from a cardboard box. Oh, he's winding up. He's gonna pounce. Get it Bumi. Pounce on it.
Good job. Did you knock it under the couch? Okay, he didn't. Thank God.
I was always Bumi. Why would it? It's always Bumi. It's always Bumi. Let's hang out. Let's hang out
for a little bit of chat. Let's just spend time together. Let's just hang out. Let people come
in because I'm very early. Let's just chill. I have a mysterious beverage next to me. I don't
recall purchasing. I think it's what's called a Shirley Temple. How was my crab? I don't know what
you're talking about. I'm streaming a lot today. This is the first time I've streamed all day.
I don't know. I'm kind of hungry. Guys think I should order some crab? You guys talking about
crab makes me want to order crab. Sorry, that's my cat. I was just to take, I feel like I should
take like a, I did something to my neck. Another crab treasure was weeks ago. That's true.
I mentioned I dream of eating crab. Maybe you'll do that tomorrow.
Let me get some water. Oh wait, did I not fill up the bread up? Freak. All right, I'll get a seltzer
water and shit.
Let me get some of this coffee.
That's not already broken.
These are already broken.
I'll have some acetaminophen.
Acetaminophen.
I hurt my neck somehow. I don't recall. This is Sheebie, my beloved.
I don't know. I'm holding up a game controller when I'm going to be using mouse and keyboard,
but you know, it is how it is. Yes, I have watched the TV series. It was pretty good.
I like that actress because she was really in like yellow jackets.
Cracking a cold one with the boys.
Yeah, it is at the normal time, but still.
So let's chat. Let's hang out. How's your day going so far?
Welcome to HairMembers. Welcome. We are doing a scary movie three watch along next week,
so I hope you'll be around for that.
Let me... It's going into my BGM, so I'm not just staring at you in the darkness and the
darkest in the silence. Got work chilling. Yeah. How's work going? If you're working right now,
how's it going? Let me take away my controller and put my hands down.
Sorry, my cat is Tokyo drifting.
Oh, there's a little boy. Put my hands... Whoa. Maybe I should change my outfit for this stream.
I think it'll change my outfit. Let's find something else.
Hmm. Well, what would be a good outfit for this stream?
Would this be a good outfit? No, I can't... I can't do that.
What are you doing, sir?
I can make myself a body of stuff again. I can bring back... I can bring... Cowboy?
I don't have any cowboy fits. I can get myself a cowboy hat.
I can... I can get myself a cowboy hat.
I don't know what you're talking about. Okay, I had an outfit. I don't know where it went,
because I was going to wear that one. I used it the other day during the doom stream and it's just
missing now. What's this? I don't know what this is. Hey, my hands are white. Don't worry about it.
This isn't it. This isn't... This isn't it. I'm going to just place myself on my bed.
All right, I'll be back here. I'm searching.
It's two hours to make... Sorry, you don't have two hours anymore.
Kind of stressed because the IRL stuff has a bunch of stuff I want to do that doesn't
know what I need to do. Take it one step at a time. Do what you can, because I know me,
I get overwhelmed thinking I have like a bunch of stuff to do. And if you literally just try like
doing at least one thing a day, it could be just a little bit helpful. Just one thing.
Where did this outfit go? It's completely gone. Oh wait, I know what happened to it. Hold on.
I never imported it. Please hold. You might see some unusual changes happen.
Do not be afraid. Do not be concerned. It is all temporary. Temporary, okay?
Everybody keeps talking about crab legs. I don't know why.
Live 2D froze. Hold on. Okay, now we're better. Please hold. I'm gonna...
I need to change the color of my skin real quick.
We're just chilling. We're just letting people come in. Muppet sheebie. I'm not gonna be a
muppet. Watch. Maybe. I could be a muppet for this. We could be a muppet for this.
Hold on. I saved my hex code. Where is it?
Uh, okay. Hex code locking in.
This is a lot of things I'll have to type. F7D2BA. I'm not typing. F7D2BA.
I like how I change from green to tan with just a single single thing.
And then we continue.
I'm just gonna slowly become brown. I'm just I'm just toasting right now.
I'm just getting a little toasty. I'll throw on my head in a moment. This is this is a model.
So how I do it, by the way, when you guys see me like put on outfits,
sometimes just putting it in the item folder doesn't work. I have to
make it a model and then import it. I don't know why. I know not everybody does that,
but I changed the colors first so I don't have to do it later because it's easier to do it this
way than through the item section. If you are wondering, if you're wondering, you can see my
legs flashing. That's a good sign. It means it means everything's going according to plan and
you don't have to be scared. All right. I'm fully transforming into my best self to my true self,
which is Dullahan. You know, I've currently lost my head. I definitely have to do a Dullahan
script writing thing. Maybe I'll write that script for October. Petrion.
And let me put that. Hopefully I recall I did all the right colors. Let's move to the other side.
Let's make this red.
Oh, I'm not sorry. That's boomy. Let's make it red.
Be a little bit on brand.
I can actually make this. That also changes color too. There's a toggle to change the color for
that. So then I click OK. Pulling a marshmallow. What?
Yeah, don't spread yourself too thin. So how are you doing a mukbang crap? What? I don't know
what you're talking about. Wait, is she being actually gyaru? No, I'm just tan.
Just because I'm tan doesn't mean I'm gyaru people. That is a totally different thing.
But anyways, so now I click on this and I do load current model as a life 2D item. And then I do that.
You do and it's loading and it's loading and it's loading and it's loading and it's loading
and it's loading. Oh, and now there's two. Fabulous save, save, cancel. Put that in the trash. And now
I'm going to transform.
I'm just, I'm just yapping and this is getting out of hand. I mean, getting out of head.
I'm just yapping because I'm not, I'm not at the time I said I would stream at. So I'm giving
people a chance to come in. So we're just hanging out. We are being chilling up in here.
It never loaded in. Oh boy. Did I do that all for nothing? Where is it?
Okay, hold on. I'm just going to close life 2D and then restart it.
Do you guys want me to like give you some inspirational stuff? Like do you want me to tell you
some good things? What do you guys going through? Let mama Shibi help you out.
Let me gas you up. You gas me up. I gas you up. Gas, gas, gas. I want to step on the gas.
Oh, yeah, yeah. Don't tell me that the thing thing is there. I know it's there.
It literally just never imported. What the hell? I'm kind of pissed, brother. What is this junk?
You want through life? Life be lifeing. Indeed.
It's a floating head? No, it's not. I don't know what you're talking about.
Maybe it, maybe it crashed.
Maybe if I leave that there.
And then I, and then I switch the model out. Maybe it'll stay. Okay, it did.
No, this is Patrick. All right, perfect. My head is up here. Let me just, this is, nope, my mole.
Sorry, I'm scratching my nose.
Hi.
Okay.
Don't worry about that. There we go. What this?
Glofts? Oh, wait, crap. Hold on. Hold on.
B2 Studio has frozen. B2 Studio has frozen. Come on, B2 Studio, I believe in you.
There we go. Now we can hang out.
Say I have a big head? That's not very nice. That's not very nice, is it?
I'm a little wiggly.
I'm sure I can come up nice and, nice and close.
This is cute. This is a cute fit. I feel, hold on. Can I add another mole?
Is this me just playing dress up constantly on stream?
That won't stay. That won't stay.
Okay. What about, oh, frick.
Can I put it on my shoulder? Because I do have, I have, I have a bunch of beauty marks.
That kind of works, I guess.
Dress to impress, but she be addition. Frick.
Put that there. Put this here. Put that,
a little, I do have a fucking big head. Jesus Christ. Put that there.
Let's add another mole, just because.
I got that, I got that real gifa. That's when I'm going to start calling it.
That real gifa. Well, no, I don't want that there. Can I put it like, well, my mole is
really down there, so it doesn't have to. Oh, actually, you know, it kind of sticks out.
This will, this will just be for the, for the screenshots.
I also have an armpit mole, but I can't really stick it in my armpit.
You know what I discovered? So I was looking at my body as a girl does, and I was just like,
I have two, so I have, hold on, let me move up. Let me put that to the side.
I discovered, where is it? I can't, here it is. I found it. Where'd it go?
I discovered I have one right here, and well, like right here and right here on each thigh,
and they're like symmetrical. I also have one of my foot.
I have one on my arm down here. I'm like, when, I'm like,
why did becoming a Vtuber show me, just make me realize how many beauty marks I have,
and I never noticed them before. I also have some in other places, but you don't need to know that.
Proof? I've posted proof. Do I have any on my knees? No.
Yeah, I have one right there, and I have one up there. That is so funny. I literally have one
right here. Is that going to stay? Oh, it kind of does. And then I have one on the other side,
a little bit higher up. Hey.
I'm trying to wink, but it's kind of hard when I turn the sensitivity down.
They say beauty marks are where you've been kissed in a past life, or where you've been stabbed.
So I could have been stabbed a lot. I also have freckles on my face, but I can't like add freckles.
Is there a freckle? Hold on.
Freckle asset Vtuber.
Free freckle assets.
Click. Yeah, but where is it? You just posted a photo of yourself.
Found it. Let's go. That's actually super cute. Oh my god, guys, I'm about to be hotter than I was before.
I used to hate my freckles.
Now I like my freckles.
Why didn't? Can I rename that?
It's such a weird show and folder. Do you like playing dress up with me?
I like playing dress up. So my mom would make fun of me and my dad because we would literally spend
the majority of our time in Destiny 2 making our characters look cool. And so anytime,
because like I would play on my computer in my room and my dad would play in the living room.
We do like cross platform or whatever. My mom's like, you guys gonna play the dress up game?
Cool. Can I draw? So now I just need to do
streaming assets, items, drag and drop the freckles into this folder. Oh, didn't mean to do that.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Please unclick and move to items. Fabulous. Close. Close.
Like I remember, I just like dressing up and making my character. Like I just,
it's just fun. It's just great. Let's see if it loaded. Oh, it did.
Is this a new character? Did I just make a new character? Am I not chibi anymore? Am I someone else?
I need a cowboy hat.
Cowboy hat. Oh, this asset is by Poproxy. Thank you, Poproxy. Cowboy hat
asset
VTuber
Wait, why do I need a cowboy hat? I don't even, someone just said I should have a cowboy hat.
I don't know why I'm getting a cowboy. Am I going to be Southern? Am I going to do Southern bell accent?
No, that's, Shabritney is actually Shabbany's real name. Shabethany, like that, Shabeti.
Southern bell bunny. Can I do a Southern accent? Oh, sugar. Of course I can do a Southern accent.
It's not that good and Azur will be very mad to hear it because she hates my Southern accent
because Azur is from the South and I don't do a Southern accent that well.
We'll hold on. We'll see. Do I have a spreadsheet? No, I don't have a spreadsheet.
I should just play Red Dead Redemption.
Now we're going to do the same thing.
Now, now, we're going to do the same thing and we're going to, we're going to put on the cowboy hat
and I'm going to look real cute with the cowboy hat on. It might take me a moment.
Bear with me. I have to do all this stuff again.
VTube studio data and I need to go streaming assets and then items and then I've already downloaded it
and it's already downloaded.
Is this the correct one? No, I don't want that one. I want this one.
Cowboy hat one. We just dropped that in there and now I have a cowboy hat.
I love childs and me and she be shimmy. I'm a dummy sister.
More VTubers need big hats.
Cowboy hat, PNG and there we go.
I am now officially, I don't know what my name should be.
I'm, I'm what should my name be? Hold on, let me move this to the, move this to the side some.
There we go. Maybe I should flip it because I'm facing the other direction.
Oh, maybe when I, when I start playing, I'm going to be looking in this direction. So maybe it's fine.
Shabelle, Shibulu, I like Shibulu. Shibulu, Shabetty, Shabetty is pretty good.
Mouse voice count. Oh my stars. It's funny. I just looked at
Azur just tweeted and just said no and I thought, I just thought she was messaging me.
Oh my God. No, it's because the Capri sons put them in bottles like somebody said. Oh my gosh.
Shabelle, that doesn't sound appropriate. I need a bigger, I have a big iron. You guys have seen my big iron.
Shabelle, because I'm a Southern, well Shabelle was supposed to be the younger sister of
Shabathani and Shibani and she's supposed to have the really high pitch voice, but I think
that this fits, this fits better. So I'll have to come up with another name for that younger sister.
But don't, don't ever think I don't keep it on me. I always be saying strap sugar.
Don't, don't, don't ever think I'm never lacking. Okay.
Every time I die, the hat will get bigger.
In fact, maybe I should shrink the hat so I can make it bigger over time. Hold on. Let me, let me just
free.
The chat break on stream, it usually does. In fact, don't worry. When I switch to the other one, it'll be
hold on. Let me just delete this and let me, let me come over here. Where's my arm?
Um, something don't look right there, but don't, don't worry about it. I'll fix that.
I don't know why that's like that. I think it's my skin tone. It looks like my arms popped off,
but you were not even going to see that. So the iron mouse.
I don't even sound like iron mouse. Iron mouse has a different voice.
Cowgirls leave me. That's just a flesh wound. I accidentally changed the color of this.
Uh, but anytime I try to look up the outfit, it's not there. I don't know why.
I'm not quite sure where it went, but I'm not going to question it.
Howdy there, Goofy.
I got the fastest whip in the west. Hold on. I got the fastest whip in the west.
Fastest whip in the west.
I also have my leash. It's kind of, it's behind my body, but don't worry about it.
Oh, wait, what's this do? I thought I could put my cover up, but it's a little won't be,
it'll be in front of me. I mean behind me.
Um,
why am I like this? Why do I just play other characters in the one that I'm supposed to
be playing? I don't know why. Don't ask me. Oh, anyways, let's, let's just play video games or whatever.
Let's just play video games or whatever.
Uh, I think it's on the launcher still. Let me just,
her madam has been kidnapped. I don't know.
Oh, my, my tongue, I think I scrubbed my tongue too hard this morning.
I don't know.
Is this working? I don't, what's up with my face? What happened?
What's going on? Hold on. I'm going to fix this. It's not working. I'm trapped.
I'm trapped in the fucking ether. Help. I can't say chat.
You say that? I can't. Please. I'm stuck in the loading screen. Why is my sensitivity for my
mouth so freaking high? Holy crap. Um,
what on earth? I can't even, doesn't even let me change the, oh, I want, I want subtitles.
Guys, it's not even letting me change the display.
Are you serious? Why was it letting me go into full screen or I can't even get it?
Help. I can't even,
this game's already freaking broken. Well, it's not broken. I'm just an idiot, but don't worry about it.
Can I just quit? I need to be able to, it's not even letting me,
help. Okay, I'm going to quit. Yes, I want to exit the game.
Please let me move. Oh my God. Finally. Raiders. Hi Raiders. Hello. Howdy, howdy, how are you doing, Raiders?
I have to save often? Okay. I hope you guys had a good stream. I know you guys were,
what were you doing? You were playing Kill of the Fire. I hope you guys had fun.
Howdy. Tipping my hat to you, sir.
Okay, let me see if I can, guys, I don't know how I'm going to do this because it's not letting me
change the game capture. It's only letting me select. Oh my God. I just hate it here.
I click play.
I try to quickly switch it over. Oh no. It pushes everything to the side and I can't see the stream.
Wait. I figured it out. Oh my God. What the hell is happening?
I figured it out. Don't worry. I found, I found a way. Hold on. There are dogs barking.
There are dogs barking.
Shabby is playing Australia. I'm playing what? I didn't put my headphones in. I haven't done that
yet. Well, now I can't see OBS. Every time I open this game, it pushes all my windows to the side,
though I have two displays. Do I have any mods? No. We're going in. We're going in vanilla and
naked. Okay. We're going in vanilla and naked. Well, slap me with butter and call me a biscuit.
Is it too loud? You can't even hear it at all, actually. Oh, shit. Hold on.
I'm going to fix this. Don't worry. Don't worry. It's small in a corner. Don't worry about it.
I don't know why it's trying to push all my windows to the demo. It looks like I'm just
never going to be able to see OBS. I'd rather see you guys than OBS, so.
That's fine. I don't know why it layers my windows one over the other, although I got two
different things. Okay. I'm chilly. There's no borderless window setting. I went to settings.
One, let me see if I can change my mouse sensitivity down. Jeez. Why is it so slow?
Oh, but it feels high. Can I just turn it off?
Whoa. I'm whipping. Let's just keep it on one and hope for the best. What is action mapping?
I don't know what that means. Oh, my God. Should I play this with a different?
Can I play this with controller? I don't even know.
Settings. Display. See, it doesn't let me. It doesn't let me pick. I don't know why that's not a thing.
Who is chilly?
Try by pressing a button. Would it be? Is it easier to play with controller? I don't.
It's actually not letting me do controller. What is going on?
I would prefer to play this with controller. Maybe if I plug it in and plug it,
I'm plugging it and plug it back in. Some of my mom always says, she said,
if you don't, if something ain't working, I'll plug it and plug it back in.
Okay. Well, now my controller isn't responsive at all.
I don't know what this just did to my controller. Anyways, looks like we can't do that.
I don't know. The world is against me today.
Ow, I just smacked the microphone. I didn't even mean to. Anyways,
am I too big? Am I too big?
Oh my God, please. No, it just closed. Oh my God.
I'm perfect. I don't know about that. I think I'm too big.
Nobody told me that my BGM was still playing.
All right. I think, you know what? I don't care anymore. We're just gonna do our best
and hope for the best.
Wait, no, I don't have a, I don't have a save game. Why is it letting me continue?
Okay. So I've never played a follow. Okay, let me just drop the stupid accent.
I've never played a follow game.
I've seen the show though. I smacked the microphone again because I'm gesturing with my hands.
Oh, Gamora and it's on fire, like Sodom and Gamora. The tops. This looks pretty good for
Vault 21, but it's outside.
What? That flame effect was actually pretty sick.
Oh.
The city looks pretty nice for
an apocalypse. I won't lie to you.
Why is he dressed so nicely? Do they have washing machines at work?
That's a dead body.
War never changes. War? They said it.
Yes.
Indeed.
Why are they all of old timey? Oh, because everything probably has to be like
not analog. It has to be analog. I don't know.
Got a little crispy even in the wasteland.
Colorado.
MCR.
My chemical romance is in this game.
It is a great aesthetic. I agree with this.
Okay.
Has anybody made a game similar to Fallout but like modern day? I feel like that does exist.
I just don't know the name of it.
I wonder what it's going to be like in 2077 when hopefully I'm dead.
But when people
they play this game at the same time, it's called a rough server metro out of worlds.
That's cool.
Help.
Give me out.
This looks weirder than
Vampire of the Masquerade to me for some reason. It's like very uncanny valley.
He just called me kitten. I'm not your discord kitten. That's a nice
gun. Is that a deagle? I don't know guns. It's not. It's not a deagle at all.
Why can I see it see through it?
Oh, okay.
It's an AK-47 understood.
Wait, Benny is Matthew Perry? That guy?
I remember watching Friends for the first time. I like when I was younger, I was watching those
shows when I really shouldn't have. It was when they already ended and everything.
And I was way too young to be watching those because I was just like I didn't get any of the
references. Friends and I thought you would come on your upper lip. Friends and how I met your mother.
Yeah, RIP Matthew Perry.
My name is Shibbell.
You're a dog or a dog? I'm deaf.
Yeah, I thought the volume was low myself. Hold on. I just turned it up for me. Let me turn it up for
you guys. Is that good?
Now I can't see the chat. Help. Turn up the volume and everybody disappears. I didn't even take my meds
and you guys are gone. Why does it keep? Okay, I'm gonna minimize these windows and then keep you
guys open. Maybe a bit loud? Oh my god. All you guys do is complain, complain, complain.
Did I take my meds yesterday? I might have forgotten.
I can't get up to max. Yeah, but then I'll be deaf.
You complain because we care. Do you? Do you really love me?
Your needlework?
Did you use Michael as golden needle? What is that?
That is not me. That's for sure. I'm a woman.
Still looks a bit all race. Hispanic.
I'm sorry. This is an African-American woman.
Let's see. Let's see. Where's my racial? Can't I be both? This game is not inclusive.
I'm about to be a white woman. No, I'm about to be Hispanic because that's my actual skin tone.
Let's change my face. Randomize.
That's the same. Sick. Nothing happened.
No. No. No. No. No. That looks good, man.
Can I change my hair? I can be like super elderly.
Hair style. What are the names of these? Oh, I clicked no. Oh, I'm just dumb.
Guys, I'm now Hispanic. I've decided. Can I? Honestly, I'm not going to lie. This is kind of a
sick haircut. I kind of want to be a VTuber with this haircut now.
It's little horns. It's like that one anime character that's like, I forget.
She's like tan, but she has like actual hair, but then her hair like goes like little whispies,
you know, seductress. Okay. I kind of have a five o'clock shadow. I don't think I like that.
Let's see what I look like when I'm African-American.
That's terrifying.
These are all terrifying, especially that one.
So this is just a brown Asian woman. Okay. Well, I guess I will be Hispanic.
Hey, where's the face that I had?
The faces are not.
Oh, this is haunting. This is it. Actually, you know what? She looks Argentinian.
She's a, she's, she's a Anna Taylor joy type where they are white, but they very fluent in Spanish.
Melted Barbie doll accurate. Oh my God. There's so many. Hold on. Let me change the color to blonde.
Oh God.
Honey. What? I don't, I can't even tell what the, this doesn't,
none of these look blonde.
I guess the honey does. Okay. So we'll do that. Blue hairstyle.
Domestic goddess. Uh, the names are interesting. Cynthia doll for progress.
Rough night. Honestly, me, this kind of looks like my hair, except it needs to be curly.
Wendy the welder.
A sophisticate. Oh, that's not, that's a nice little bun.
Frazzled. She'll click. She's on cocaine.
Iron maiden. Understandable. On ladylike. Okay.
Rude ridge. Mange. Fallen eight.
What are these fucking hairstyles? Fairy tale. Why is everything shaved?
Bedraggled. Me. Blast back. The unsettler. Clean cut. Pretty puff. Sarge. Okay. These are just men's
hairstyles. Uh, I guess I'll be seductress. What does that mean? I'm kind of scared.
Radiation. She be, she be cottonballed.
The wasteland is a disaster on hair.
I, I would still be hip with the trends. I would still, I have a big ass forehead
because I have a lot of knowledge here in my garage, but I, I, I'm still with the trends. Yes.
I am a white looking Hispanic woman named Chabelle.
My last name is Chabelle. Castillo. Because that's the first Spanish last name that pops up in my hand.
Why are you guys insulting my hairstyle?
Where, why are you looking, why am I so much taller than you? Can I shoot you?
All right. It's not a race. Well, oh, I'm already, it's auto, auto run.
Ooh. I don't like how you said that.
Uh, the what?
The Vino-Matic veer tester.
E. What are the names of these things?
I'm reading, you spell anarchy a very weird way.
This is like, oh, like when you were at like an arcade and you would like squeeze something and it was weird.
Why are there? Oh, what?
Rate your strength perception, endurance, charisma, intelligence, agility, and luck.
Oh, I like how it spells out special. That's pretty cool.
Okay. So my strength, um, strength, this is a lot of, I'm a wet noodle. Can I be a wet noodle?
I want to be a baby. Just go with what feels right. A beach. I'll be a doughy baby.
So I can put everything into strength. Okay. I'll be a doughy baby.
Wait, I have so many points.
Can I just max everything to seven then? Oh, no, I see. Okay. Understood. Understood.
I'm a doughy baby. Perception.
Oh, I'll be an unsuspecting trout.
Hello for the students to survive. I'm, I'm, I'm flamer tartan. That's for sure. I'm a cult leader.
I'll be a, I'll be a, I'll be a diplomat. Let's turn this to tough as nails.
Intelligence. I'm knowledgeable. I got knowledge. Agility. Catlike.
Luck. Leprechaun's foot.
I don't know what any of this means.
Yep.
Sorry, the background music, I can barely fucking hear what you're saying.
My dogs? I can't see them. Hey, this was at the carpet I tried to order and put on thrown.
Uh, sit. Oh, what the? Why am I just, I'm not wearing any.
Yeah, I can't read though. Cat.
House. Burglar eyes. Night.
Shroud dream. Bandit. Stab.
Light.
Tark. Mother. Cookie jar.
Okay. Now I got a few states. I want you to tell me how much they sound like something you'd say.
I can scroll from our options while it's too late. Conflict just ain't in my nature.
Uh, I disagree. I can handle conflict. I ain't given to rely on others for
support. No, I disagree. I can rely on other people. I'm always fixing to be the center of
attention. I like attention, but if I'm in a group, I don't want to be the center of attention.
So I'll put no opinion. I'm slow to embrace new ideas. No, I like new ideas. Disagree. I charge
in to deal with my problems head on. Incorrect. I have to think about everything. What do you say
you have a look at this? That looks like explosions.
That looks like a chemical reaction. Is there an explosion? I see two
explosions on either side. A broken chain. I guess I'll do a chemical reaction. Okay.
How about this one? This looks like a great rune.
It looks like a pee pee.
There's no, I don't see great ruin as a, as a,
as a BuzzFeed quiz. Am I, yeah, what? I didn't expect any of this. Um,
it doesn't look like a coochie to me. I'll say space age technology.
Last one. These look like two gnomes holding hands.
None of these are the answer. These are two gnomes holding hands.
A head on a pillow because that just sounds weird.
Okay.
What does this even mean?
Energy weapon skills. I don't know what that means.
Is this, is this going to tell me my future?
This just gave me skills based on my answers. That's what I'm good at.
All right. I'll just, I'll keep what I gave me. I'll, I'll, I'm going in so vanilla.
Do you need to do a pap smear? Like you're asking a lot from me, bro.
So you do need a pap smear.
Hold on. I put on subtitles. I don't know why they're not there.
I put on dialogue subtitles. Wait, where are they? I think it's on display.
Yeah. Dialogue subtitles are on, but I guess I gotta put those on.
Choose up to two traits.
Critically hit small frame. My limbs are more easily crippled.
Bizarre and silly elements. Am I like, is, what is this? Like the one thing from that one,
the Malkovians or whatever they are from the Empire of the Masquerade?
Wild wasteland. Okay. Wild wasteland and I'll do,
I'll do fast shot.
Wait, what's four eyes?
Glasses? Oh my God. No, I, I do wear glasses. So I don't, I don't want to,
I am good at talking.
Which is the other one I should pick?
It adds jokes and memes for movies? Oh, I'm glad.
Help me pick.
Sorry. You want to pick any of the rest of them? All right.
All right. I guess that about does it. Do you need to, do you need to look at my teeth
before you sell my organs? I can't get up. Oh, why am I, I look, I just look like a white woman.
That's fine. Documential.
That name sounds so familiar. I feel like I've seen references of him in something else.
Here, these are yours.
Was all you had on you when you was brought in? I hope you don't mind, but I gave the note a look.
I thought it might help me find the next of kin, but it was just something about a platinum chip.
Well, if you're hidden back out there, you ought to have this. Can I have clothes?
They call it a Pip Boy. I grew up in one of them vaults and made before the war. We all got one.
You know, the, the, the mouth tracking is quite impressive.
You've been through. I know what it's like having something taken from you.
And put this on too so the locals don't pick on you for lack in modesty.
Was my wife. That's so kind. I think she was about your size
and she hardly wore it after we left the vault. Felt it was too brazen.
What does that mean?
Thank you. I don't mention it. It's what I'm here for.
You, you thank you. You should talk to Sunny Smiles before you leave town.
She can help. Sunny Smiles, I need a cool last name.
I should be Shabelle. Shabelle Cottonbun.
For free? I'll try my best.
Follow New Vegas as you play a new hardcore mode. No. Recommended.
Okay. Um, thank you.
Shabelle Styles Boom.
Don't forget to put my clothes on. How do I put my clothes on?
Oh, this looks like the house from, um,
or that guy was like trying to screw a chicken.
Tab. Oh, radiation.
Uh, oh, that's cool how it moves up and down.
Honestly, this game is ahead of its time. Items.
All weapons fall under a skill and the base damage and
that was for second condition repair slash mod respectively. Okay.
Oh, I only have a later. Can I put that apparel?
Apparel. Okay. I'm sorry. I'm just reading it. I'm not going to read everything out loud.
Mm-hmm.
And I got a sim pack. I'm assuming bobby pins are for picking locks.
Energy weapons.
Maintain. Okay.
Am I wearing clothes? I can't tell.
I got naked. I'm naked now.
I thought, oh, is that my arm?
Oh, okay.
I can press F for third. Oh, damn. I kind of got that figure.
This is pretty nifty.
Wait, why do I look like naked?
Oh, boring.
21.
I don't want to steal anything from his house.
This man just braids me from the dead, although, you know, I would steal stuff
because I like to be a kleptomaniac in games. I'm like a little crow. I like to collect trinkets.
Trinkets? Okay. Oh, I can. How do I take out my gun? I don't know. It doesn't matter.
Worst sunny smiles. How do I see what the objective is? Question?
It's in the tab menu.
Um, is it data? Oh, I can play music. Quests. Show location.
I can't. Can I scroll?
I can't tell if that's the center of my screen. What's that dot? Oh, no, it's fast travel.
Okay, so I'm assuming I just go straight ahead.
Compass bottom left. I did notice that.
Music is heavily copyrighted. Okay, that's fun.
There's a nice little place, you know. I wish I had a saloon.
Prospector, solid.
Am I supposed to go in here? I wish it would actually give me like an indicator.
Hi. Hi, EZP. Howdy. What can EZP- You look like Morgan Freeman. Why are you called EZP?
Was a prospector until I decided to settle here to get away from the NCR.
Now I'll just take it easy and help out with the Brahmin and Big Hornet.
Brahmin? Like Hinduism? Question. What's wrong with the NCR?
Don't get me wrong. The NCR has got a lot of decent fork in it. It's just that they make
you part of them whether you like it or not. Towns like Goodsprings and Prim don't stay independent.
The arrow is my indicator. Okay, thank you. Not if you've got something the NCR.
Oh, that's right. Because it's a two-headed cut. That's right. I remember seeing that in the show.
Okay, cool. I don't really need to know anything else. How do I get out of here? How do I escape?
Can I leave? How do I stop talking to you?
Help. How do I stop? Oh, goodbye.
Thank you, Morgan Freeman. Okay, they must be inside.
That was the shittiest line delivery I've ever heard in my life.
Cheyenne, stay. Don't worry. She won't bite you.
You can teach me to survive. I guess there's a thing or two I could show you.
Sounds like you need all the help you can get after what they done to you.
Meet me outside behind the saloon. Thanks, Queen. Can I pet your dog? Can I pet that dog? Can I pet that?
Where the fuck did the dog go?
Your dog face through the door, ma'am. I think you got us. You got it. I don't think your dog's real.
I think you're Delulu. Where the fuck did you go? The hell?
Hello? Wait, is that something I can steal? Steal, steal, steal, steal. Oh, it's a workbench. Cool.
Can I pet that dog? You're so pretty.
Take this and try to hit a couple of them. Sarsaparilla. Take what?
Everything all right? I know I'm confused. Until next time.
I feel like I'm playing Skyrim. Oh, you gave me the gun already. How do I? Where are the bottles?
I don't, can I just shoot you? No, I won't do that.
Bottles on the fence next to the bar.
And I wish I could go a little bit faster. Buddy, they're right there. Yeah, but I'm fucking, oh,
okay. Can I pet that dog? Can I pet that dog?
All right, rooting two in, shooting. Can I scope? Oh, I can. What the hell?
Am I actually crazy? That was really weird.
I want to go back to first person.
Staying still. 360 nose, go. 360 nose, go.
You want me to kill some lizards? Okay.
I like the geckos though.
Can I pet that dog? Why is that dog wearing like that? I think your dog is disease, man.
Can I shoot your butt? Can I shoot your butt and steal your dog? I would like to keep your dog.
Why do we all have nice asses? I just really want to shoot. Can I give you a second butthole?
Can I give you a third hole? Why am I so tall compared to everybody?
Press V to make life easier? Oh, what the hell?
What?
What the fuck?
Can I steal your gun? Varmint, right? What?
That's a, you see, I've seen that before and I never really understood how it worked because
I've seen like a little bit of gameplay of fallout games. Auto targeting, I see.
Excuse me puppy, puppy, you gotta move. Mom is trying to get through.
Why is that dog so huge? I think you have a wolf. This doesn't really look like a like a dog dog.
Oh my god.
I don't like your face.
I'm a man that's outside the game. I don't know what you're talking about.
I missed everything that she said because you guys were talking. I can pit pocket you.
I don't see any. Kill the geckos at the whale? Am I supposed to be crouching?
Hello? What the hell? Oh, uh, you're bigger than I thought.
Yeah, sick and puppy. One of my cats is doing something behind me. Or it's the game I can't tell.
Hello? Is that it?
See ya. Is that considered stealing? I'm walking in it. It's probably on sanitary.
Oh, is she dead? Oh, I thought that was her body on the ground.
Hello. Sorry, I walked away from you.
You want you can come along and be worth a few caps to me.
How about a pop a cap in your ass? More than a couple minutes, especially with two of us.
Okay, cool.
Let's go puppy.
There's bigger ones. Girl, can you just walk and stop stopping waiting for me to catch up?
I'm right behind you. I'm on your ass. Your dog's kind of in the way, but that's fine.
The dog isn't no better. It kind of looks like it has a broken leg.
I almost shot the dog.
I'm trying not to shoot the dog.
Oh, puppy. Are you okay?
Do you care about your dog at all? They literally just attacked your dog,
and you're just walking away. You're not even checking on your dog.
Cheyenne. No. Puppy, you have two bullets in you. Did I do that? What?
Y'all, hold on. Somehow my chat scrolled up.
Those are its eyes on the side.
I don't even know where this lady fucking went. I hope they kill her.
That'll be funny in the tutorial if they just killed her. Did you kill them all?
Oh, nice. What else are you fucking shooting at? It's running. Get that vomit.
I can't. I can't run that far. Fast. Oh, get got. Get got. Get got. Back up.
Get fucking. These geckos are big.
That was it. I saw way more geckos. I saw way more. Oh, what's over here?
Is there stuff I can steal?
What's this? Is that bottles of water? It's a milk bottle? Oh, okay. Milk.
I think it's using it. It ain't stealing. Okay.
I'm just looking for something to take. Don't worry about it. Can I please run faster?
Do I need that?
Take a bucket. Did you heal your dog? Your dog has two bullets in it.
Oh, hell's bells. There's not a day passes by. I don't tell people. Hold R. Okay.
Some people, your word just isn't good enough for them. Then this happens.
Well, it's a part of what happens. Do people die because of the geckos? Staying out here with me.
Here's my end of the deal. One more thing I wanted to show you. That's a lot of auto-cash.
I might teach you about living off the land and making useful things for yourself.
Interested? Yippee. All right, then. We'll need a couple ingredients to get started.
Gonna want some Xander root and a Brock flower. Xander root. What do you think now?
I know I've seen Brock flowers growing up with the gravy. Bring those on.
Okay, that's great. At the graveyard, I don't even, what the fucking, you're talking like I know
where I'm going. I'm assuming I gotta climb shit. Fly. Where do I go? I'll always go up this way.
All right. Heal your fucking dog, lady. I have a map.
I pressed M. It didn't work.
Oh.
F3. F3 is the map?
That doesn't make no fucking sense. All right. Well, I'm going to this one first.
Can I climb? Can I vault? No. I'm not like a Skyrim horse. That's too bad.
Can I harvest their gecko meat? What's up with the music? It's not that deep.
Wait. Okay, I'm getting closer.
Yes, sometimes. Oh, I'm on auto run if I press Q. Wait, how do I stop? Okay.
Am I, did I walk past it?
Hello?
What the fuck is attacking me? What are these?
How do I?
Oh, what the fuck? I just rocked that bug. I don't stop.
So, oh, I have like a certain percentage. All right.
Pew.
All right.
Uh.
Is this it? This is a fucking bush.
I can see myself live in here. This is a nice area. Is it this?
Bro, what is? I can't even find a damn plant.
I'm literally right on top of it. I don't. This is a dead tree.
Roy, what?
How do I?
Brother, look down. I'm standing on it next to the tree stump.
Oh, okay. I'm looking down.
How do I?
Guys, what the fuck?
Playing first person?
I don't. Am I an idiot? I don't.
Do I see the three plants hidden? I am playing Skyrim.
They're brown with green stalks. Is it these things? I can't grab them.
I'm in the fucking tree. No, behind me? Oh.
Uh, okay. I'm not in this. I'm blind. I'm just a little bit blind. Okay. Like, leave me.
Let me live my life.
Wasn't expecting cowgirl sheebie. Howdy. It's me, Shabelle.
I don't know where I'm going. I don't know what I'm looking for. I should just put
myself in this fucking dumpster because that's where I belong. I'm a piece of trash.
Just kidding. You be riding there with me because you're literal trash.
The game like others brown for the times. What does that mean?
It's that little dust devil. Can that hurt me? No.
Am I fighting something?
What the fuck is this targeting system? Like, I can't hit shit.
Like, I don't... I want to hit this head.
How many?
What was that?
Can I eat it?
I can't eat it. It looks like crab and I want crab.
Brown scale. Oh, okay. I didn't know that. What the hell are these things?
I'm fighting a fucking fly. Why is everything in slow mo? This is literally like...
Oh, wait. I forgot that they also made the same game. I was like, why is this so much like
Skyrim? And I'm like, because I'm an idiot and they made the same thing.
Up you. I'm just going to waste all my ammo.
I'm standing still.
Danger. Oh my god. Can I just fucking punch it?
Anyways, whatever. Let me just...
Can I have that lantern? Is that a can? I spanked up a can.
Does my health regen or do I need like a Stimpac?
Bro, do I literally have to target every time?
How are you still alive?
I can't even see.
That's my grave. Yes, I could tell. The fact I like...
I shoot something head on like it's in my crosshair perfectly and I still
fucking... Is there just an insane bullet drop off?
They really just want me to use this each time. Let me just do body.
Shoot again. Thank you.
This is such a weird mechanic. Is this it?
I did it.
See, this is why most modern games make it so objects go if you interact with them.
Oh, understandable. Thank you for the don't know.
How do you hit the brain? I don't know. Bullet drop doesn't even exist.
Because like... Do I... Is it because I'm not looking down sights? Is there another one? Hold on.
I'm literally gonna like... To be a little bit ahead. Okay,
so I just have to be a little bit above.
I feel a pain in this for a reason. Understandable.
At least I have a shit ton of ammo for no reason. I bet she's gonna take the gun
back from me though. What?
Can I rebuild my character?
Oh, let's change.
Have you Asian? Never mind.
What are the Caucasian faces look like?
Okay, they all look goofy.
How do I get out of here? No, wait.
Hell, can I cancel?
Hell, spam next.
No, I have to do this again.
All right, well, I gotta remember what I am. Hold on. I gotta be Hispanic.
Next. I can customize? What?
What was I, this one? Yes, I was. And then I do my hair color, honey.
Not pecan, honey.
And then let me change the hairstyle. What was I? Seductress. Perfect.
Wait, I want to see if I can customize my...
Behind my eyes are blue. You see my blue eyes?
Okay. I look like I'm blind, but that's fine. I can have a tough moment.
Yeah. What?
I have to do all this again?
Okay, let me go look in my vault and see what I did.
Please hold.
Hold. Where is it?
Okay, somebody write this down. Three, four, seven, seven, five, six, eight.
I didn't even need you guys. I memorized it because I'm a fucking baller.
Oh, yes, that was fine. And then I have wild wasteland.
Finished.
All right, don't worry about it.
And then I have wild wasteland.
Finished. All right, no, never let me do that again.
Three, six, seven, five, three, oh, wait, no. Six, eight, seven, five, three, oh, nine, nine.
Oh, what do I do now? I just go in this direction.
Do I get a horse?
Save then look at quests. Save. Save. I have a thousand saves.
There are no horses. I should just play Red Dead Redemption. What is this?
I always move on foot. What the hell? Is that a charge?
The world might explode by Jesus still lives. He has risen just like my pee pee map.
Oh, it's scrolling the fucking
chat. All right, let's travel, boys. Wait, you guys said I need to check.
Quests. Bring the Brock flood. Oh, I have to give that back to her.
And then find the man that tried to kill you. But this is back in the saddle.
Why would they do this to me? Why would they lie? Now I'm just going to walk fast.
Watch out for scorpions.
Red lines are enemies. Well, it looks like I'm fine then. I was wondering what those were.
Oh, I see. I see. I see.
How did I get all the way over here? How did she get over there? I feel like I didn't travel that far.
The horses went extinct, but we have fucked up cows. Make that make sense.
Do I get a car? Can I get a little bicycle? Just give me a just give me a mountain bike.
And we got roads.
Empty arrows are unfound locations, understood. I follow two of a car.
No vehicles at all. I'm about to install some mods. Is that a dude? Is he friendly? Can I kill him?
Can I pickpocket him? No, I won't do it. I'll fight the urge.
Heal. Heal. Did I fall damage? Yep. Guys, I have fall damage.
Let me see what you got. Yeah, these will do. Just fine. Just fine.
I don't like how you said that. I'm going to be making something folks on the trail call healing
powder. Okay. Come on over to that campfire now. Give it a try.
Let's gather around the campfire. I'm literally right fucking next to it.
All healing powder except I can make anti-venom. How many? One.
Hey, that's not bad. See all it takes to make a recipe is the right ingredients.
Why is your name Sunny Smiles? You don't smile at all. You know you should smile more.
Thing to get is it's all the same idea. You just need to find the right place to set up shop
workbench or reloading bench whatever. Well, I hope that's enough to get you started. Okay. I'm
heading back now. Hope I didn't miss anything good on the jukebox. Sian would never forgive me.
She's a dog. Trudy. She's the bartender up at the prospector. Kind of the town mom. Okay. She likes
to meet newcomers. Cool. She'd be cross with me if I didn't ask you to poke your head in and say hi.
Yeah. Did you heal your dog yet?
I'm taking your dog. You are an abusive parent.
Wait, how is my Tamagotchi doing? I don't even know where it went.
I don't know where my Tamagotchi. Oh, I found it. Let's check on my Tamagotchi.
Oh, my God. Why does it look like that? It looks like a
poop. It really looks like a piece of poop. I'm not even joking. It looks like a piece of poop.
I have a shit child.
Why is my child ugly? The first one was the best one of them all. I think I just keep jinxing myself.
Here, have some food. Eat some cereal. That's all. Oh, actually, I kind of want to eat some cereal.
Should we take a cereal break, boys? Because I've done so much so far. I just finished this
tutorial, so I think I deserve a treat. I think I deserve some Cheerios.
If you want a break already. Listen, I have been doing nothing all day. I deserve a break.
I
wish it would rain today. I want some rain. I want to watch a scary movie.
My boobies hurt. What kind of Cheerios? I don't know. Cheerio kind? Is this honey not Cheerios?
Oh
What do you want me to say?
Can we watch a scary movie too? No. Only me. I was debating.
I was debating whether or not to go to the movies to see Alien Romulus by myself. And I'm just like,
uh-oh. I'm thinking about it.
Honey, not take the hair and plush with. Oh, I could do that.
I
know my dad's too scared to see it. I told you guys before
I told you guys before
that I brought it up my mom. I was telling my mom. Hold on. My model froze again. I was telling my mom.
Um
Not like I wanted to see Alien Romulus
and then my mom I'm like, but I don't have anybody to go with and then my mom looks at my injustice to my dad
and I was just like, oh, why didn't you go with her? And I looked at her and I'm like, dad's a pussy.
He's too scared.
I said that verbatim.
And then he cursed me out in Creole and they don't know what he said.
Um
And I said, mom, we were literally watching the previews before Deadpool and Wolverine
in the Alien Romulus trailer came on and he started screaming
his grown ass
six five
bald buff black man was just screaming like a little girl. You guys heard his high like his voice gets really high
That's what it sounded like in the theater. He was like, ah, I'm like dad shut up
He would just be closing his eyes the entire time
My dad's a scaredy cat. He can't handle scary movies
Can I take on a xenomorph sexually? Yes, physically. No
Couldn't beat the wolf's allegations
Like I'm I like I can be a wolf wolf sometime
No
How about my mom?
Honestly, you know, my mom is really funny because my mom is very she hates my mom hates violence
She hates anything with violence
And like when me and my dad watch like a more violent movie or whatever she like will be like, I can't watch this
This is gonna give me nightmares
But then one day I go and visit and my mom's watching like seal team
On whatever platform it is and I'm like I'm like mom soldiers are dying in this
And being shot, but you can watch it make that make sense mother. She's like, I don't know
I don't know why
And I'm like if you have night terrors don't come crying to me
I want to play amnesia what what's happening here my camera is spinning. It's fine
AFK spin. I'm gonna get fucking motion sick stop
Terrorizer, I don't know. I there's never been a
Uh horror movie. I haven't been able to finish
Um, although like I've never seen the saw movies
I don't mind body horror, but like I don't I don't think I don't like it when it's like realistic
Although that's a lie because I like gore. I like gore a lot
Maybe maybe I need to watch saw
I've heard of terrorizer
Grandparents pretty religious of watching gory ass horror movies. That's kind of funny
I
First few saw is our peak. Maybe we'll do a spooky spooky movie watch along. Um during
October
Cabin, oh, I like cabin in the woods cabin in the woods is really good because I like the twist
Yeah
I
Terrorizer splatter gore porn effects no purpose
Odd
Thoughts on religious horror is that considered a religious horror
I did it's just like it's just
I like the conjuring. I don't think it's religious horror. It's just like it's just like spiritual horror
Exorcist, well, yeah, I could see the exorcist
Oh
No, I'm spinning again
That's scary so religious maybe that's what makes sense. Okay, hold on. Let me get let me get some cereal
So we heal in milk. Oh
Oh
You're not liquid
Did you get the people
Right now see the chair. Hi, I can't get to you though because you're under the chair
I'm
Had work. Maybe it's gonna go on a funeral day today
Dinner love me some
My tummy's probably never hurt.
Because of the milk.
I kind of just want something sweet and funny, not Cheerios.
It's all that I have.
Here's my boobie.
Metro boobie.
What's for dinner? Cereal?
Yes, I think I have the lambs.
No lactate? No.
Yes.
Why would I have cereal with yogurt?
We're in spin without the egg.
There's a lot of new people here.
What's up with that?
Who are you?
Hi, my name's Shibi Kanbum.
I am lactose intolerant, but I also eat cereal,
even though it's lactose-free milk and it's leaving me my tummy hort.
I'm your favorite girl failure dom.
Avila's Gen 1 Indulge.
New Vegas delivers?
Interesting.
Well, if you're amused so far, please leave a like or dislike.
That's funny.
Don't forget to subscribe.
I have three cats, Boomi, Fia, and Reina.
Reina's staring at me right now because she wants my cereal.
I love all my lurkers.
I appreciate the lurkers.
Thank you.
I know if you're really new gen mates,
but I'm watching right now because of the New Vegas.
I'm not even lying. That's what Reina looks like right now.
What the fuck just happened?
Reina, stop staring at me like this.
Crunch, crunch.
Mm-mm, delicious.
I know it's an idle camera pan.
I mean my model in-game, not my vtuber model.
It just kind of fell for a second.
I was up in the air, then I landed on the ground.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
What are you doing?
Okay.
Boomi, you can't have it.
Boomi's on my desk trying to take my cereal out.
He's going for it.
I don't know why it didn't attack me.
Do you ever have a little bit of warm milk left in your bowl?
So you put some more cereal?
That's what I like to do.
What a healthy, balanced dinner.
Or dinner.
Boomi, go away.
My son is trying to steal my cereal.
Boomi, Boomi, right now this is not for you.
I will drink the extra milk.
And I will like it.
I don't like soggy cereal.
That's gross.
That's disgusting.
You ever put milk in the cereal bag to moisten the cereal?
Anyways.
You want me to reinforce his bad behavior by giving him milk?
No.
Ow.
Glutty.
Glutty usually meal prep and I will do it based off of that.
Milk is bad for kitty tummies.
Raina throws up when she has milk.
Glutty.
I have barbecue mac and cheese.
What?
Hello?
Gunfire?
You really want to kill my cat, Tom?
Yogurt and cereal?
I've never tried it.
I like yogurt and granola.
Actually.
No, one time I ran out of granola so I put honey bunches of oats.
No.
Boomi's lawyer is trying to kill his own client.
He's just trying to take the money and run.
What is Ranger mode starving?
I can have, I have to eat?
I keep getting escaped.
La la la.
It's night time. The sky is pretty.
The stars at night are being bright.
Deep in the heart of Texas.
That's a difficulty? No, thank you.
And the burp.
Are you ready for the burp?
Okay, a little bit of Cheerio came up with that.
That didn't sound that good.
I also forced it.
I can fast travel? Impressive.
Ten out of ten.
That wasn't even that good.
That wasn't even a good burp.
There was no base in that. That was all treble.
I like my beads fast in my base down.
Where's the other one?
Hello?
Is that one?
I definitely scrubbed my tongue too hard.
My tongue hurts.
Unless I scratched it when I had those dream crab legs in my sleep.
Well, I like Ten's.
I like being spoiled.
How do I feel so far about the game?
I'm just playing Wasteland Skyrim, so I like it.
Hey.
Perhaps.
I need to get to Prim.
With the roller coaster.
You never know who you'll run into.
Off the road, you'll probably start running into hostile wildlife.
My advice would be to stick to the highway when you can.
Okay.
That's fine.
Bye.
Until next time.
Thanks, ma'am.
Excuse me.
You have a weird look about you.
Piss?
Why does he want piss?
That's weird.
Hi.
You have really weird concealer.
What was that all about?
Oh.
Not Ringo Star?
Not Piss Man?
Why is everything so foggy in here?
I feel like I'm looking through dirty glasses.
Where is he now?
Wow, that's crazy.
Thank you for giving me that information.
Now I'm going to go sell that.
I don't know.
I'll kill him.
Shabelle has a clock coma.
I can sell him out.
I just want to be a shit human being in this game.
That's why they shot me in the head.
What are you going to do?
Powder gangers.
They sell crack.
I'm going to show them a sticker.
Dynamite up your ass.
Okay.
The robot?
I know that thing as much as anyone else around here.
What?
You don't like him?
It acts friendly enough, but I don't trust that whole cheerful cowboy act.
There's a robot?
Very creepy.
Go, go, powder gangers.
Did Ranger Rejects come out?
I want to watch that.
I should just read the manga, but what does he actually do?
Other than rolling around once in a while,
it doesn't do anything useful as far as I can tell.
I don't know why it took an interest in you,
but I'd be careful.
It's never helped anyone before.
Okay.
It was here when I took over the saloon seven years ago.
Some people have said its owner lived here,
but no one knows who it was.
It's fine by me.
I don't like that I have to say,
let's talk about something else instead of just me just saying the dialogue,
something like myself.
You know anything about him?
Not much other than there are a bunch of freeloaders
who expected a few rounds on the house.
I was able to get them to pay up though.
Of course, one of the great cons did not-
He dug me out of the grave?
What the fuck?
It hasn't been working since.
So I could have just suffocated.
I don't care about your radio.
They were having some kind of argument about it,
but the guy in the checkered coat kept shushing-
I'm going to say it.
I don't care that you broke your elbow.
If that's the case, I can't say I blame them
for not wanting to go back.
What's your function?
That whole area is overrun with the kind of critters
that just get mad if you shoot them.
Merchants avoid that whole stretch of I-15
like it's radioactive,
which it could be for all I know.
Yeah?
So where are they headed?
I didn't hear exactly, but the leader was talking about the strip.
Fella wants to get there and avoid the 15.
He'd have to go east.
What am I, California?
That was weird. Her voice changed.
What do you got for sale?
Dirty water.
Is rads radiation?
Iguana on a stick!
Junk food.
Moonshine, meeting people.
Should I buy any of these from her?
I just want to set the world on fire.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Bye bye.
Be careful out there.
Yeah, I remember watching that in school.
That's the only thing I remember.
Not from school, I mean, like, just that, like, I don't know why they're playing a set video.
Gentlemen.
Interesting.
The women's bathroom is delectable,
what the gentleman's bathroom has seen better days.
Can I piss in here?
Did I just drink from the toilet?
I thought I clicked activate.
Why am I drinking from the toilet?
How am I drinking from the sink?
It's not even on.
Might as well, I was drinking water, how I heal.
That doesn't make any sense to me, but okay.
Uh, yep, I did notice my HP rises.
Who is calling me? It's spam.
Hold on, I'll pick up.
Fuck your mother!
Okay.
And I just hung up.
I'm gonna start doing that next time I get spam calls in stream.
Watcha be like...
I don't even know.
What if like...
What if Grog girl was calling me and she just...
I just yelled in her face.
Where do I go?
Do I have to do this?
Okay.
I don't really care about that, I'll track that instead.
I don't care about that silly quest.
Honestly, I'm not someone who really cares about side quests a lot.
I prefer just to stay on the main quest.
So there's something right there, and there's something over there.
So Prim's over there.
I know.
What's that?
I want to know what it is.
Do I turn a little bit?
This way?
Okay, let's go.
I have a laser pistol.
I don't...
I don't need no laser pistol.
I got a fucking...
Puppy!
Cheyenne, you're coming with me!
Oh, she still didn't heal you yet.
Anyways.
They're like a weird hop skip jump.
Oh, is this the robot?
Hey.
Yes, sir! Thank you for digging me out of that grave!
But apparently you never helped anyone before.
I don't like your fucking crazy eyes.
I'm not going to accidentally kill the dog.
Why do you look like Metaton?
Did they base Metaton after you?
Don't make fun of VTuber for so long.
I don't know, he needs to work on his eye rigging.
I'm a Securitron.
Robco Security Model 2060B.
He's bigger than my 1070.
Sick, bye!
Happy Trails!
It's Metaton!
Can I fuck the robot?
Um...
Anyways.
So I have to walk all the way to Prim?
Okay.
Is the mod for everything?
Later?
I can do another...
I can fuck the robot in this game.
Because VT got me acting some kind of way, you know?
Maybe in a robot mood.
I don't even know how that works, I have to look that up.
Can somebody recommend me some Robohentai?
I've just suddenly decided I want to be into it.
But I don't know the schematics.
How do I take out my gun?
My pistol.
His name is Fisto!
Click to draw. No, but that just draws my other gun.
So if I go to the items, and I go to weapons...
A pew pew!
What?
Okay.
Well this gun is broken, so what's the point?
I shot it once and it's already fucking broken.
How much ammo do I have?
Okay, I have 20 left.
I've discovered where the ammo counter is.
Don't look at me like that.
I don't like that I can hear whistling.
Okay, there's enemies.
But what kind of enemies?
Seeing enemies?
Little bars, it's durability.
Understood.
Enemy spotted.
I think I'm sciency enough.
Because I have the sciency trait, I think.
I shouldn't have said that.
I haven't done much, but I'm getting a little sleepy, I'll be honest with you.
I haven't even really gotten far at all.
But I want to keep playing, but I'm really tired.
I shouldn't have streamed earlier today.
I mean, I didn't do that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What are you doing?
He's standing there menacingly.
You dare approach me?
Sleep stream of the harem, you guys are just going to hear me snore.
Stop.
How are you not fucking dead?
Well, I'm going to shoot you in the fucking head.
How about that?
Jesus Christ.
Anyways, there's another one.
What?
Bitch.
You don't care if I don't snore attractively.
You guys think snoring is...
My parents...
My mom woke me up in the middle of the night one time.
She heard me choking because I was snoring so bad.
And then they recorded me snoring because I don't think I've ever snored before.
And I sounded like a fucking monster.
It's going well.
I think, I don't know.
I'm like skipping like a weirdo.
Is this Prim?
Primrose, Aberdeen.
Okay, cool. Thank you.
Hi. Jesus, am I playing oblivion?
What's going on?
Everyone inside is either dead or in hiding.
What's more, there are two tribes of raiders causing trouble in this area as well.
You'd be safer heading back up to Goodsprings.
Thanks for the warning.
Shouldn't you be fucking protecting the town?
I'd love to, but they don't fall under NCR jurisdiction.
Even if they did, we're in no shape to protect them.
So you're useless.
Why can't you protect them?
We don't have the equipment to take out the convicts.
And even if we did...
And why are you here?
You sound actually useless.
He's in a tent down the road.
Stay on the west side of the overpass.
You don't want to get shot.
I don't want to get shot.
He's fucking zoomed in on his face.
All right.
I'm so tired.
I don't know why.
Oh, I know why.
How do I...
Can I, like, double-click?
He's in a tent.
How the fuck do I get in there?
Yeah!
I have to cross that funky little bridge.
Funky-ah bridge.
Ooh, water?
Can I have it?
Empty soda bobble.
What's a Legion run?
Ooh, watch the mask.
Enjoy!
I haven't seen that moving in a while.
Who's detected?
Who has me detected?
Who's detecting me?
Do you think I'd be able to call in there?
Hello?
It's fine.
I can be a little rat.
Can I see?
It's fine.
What are you guys talking about?
Landmines? I didn't see any landmines.
Aw.
Sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
Sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
Sneak.
Can I, like...
Can I pick up on him?
Ah!
Hold on, I'm reloading.
My eyes closed.
I look like a really wonky marbidol.
No, I didn't save.
Where am I?
Baker hat.
Fine.
I gotta make my hat bigger.
Please hold.
Yippee!
How far back?
What?
How far back did I...
Yeah, I don't think it's that bad.
I think it saved automatically when I left the thingy.
Yeah, I just have to talk to Victor again.
Hold on.
Yeah.
We're fine.
I just have to walk.
I may fall asleep on the way, but that's fine.
What are you doing?
Where is he?
Where's the...
Huh?
Is he over there?
Okay, I think...
Marker's Ringo.
Oh, that's right, and I switched it.
Oh, okay.
What the hell?
Yeah, there he is!
Ron!
What is this?
Oh, you don't look too good, brother.
Hi, Medeton!
Howdy, partner!
Thanks.
Thank you!
Yippee-ki-yay!
I wish I had a fucking horse.
Where's Torrent when I need him?
Let me save.
Why doesn't it auto-save?
Turn on the radio?
How do I turn on?
I
Can I turn it off?
Oh.
I don't care if the music gets claimed, I'm not really...
I don't make any money from streaming anyways.
I mean, not from like...
I meant like ad stuff, I don't really care.
Yeah, like, most I'll get is like 20 bucks, so it's not a big deal.
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't make any money from streaming, guys.
Bealur takes every penny.
No, kidding.
Our predatory 20% cut.
No, I'm kidding.
What's that? Can I pick it up?
Ooh, sure.
We definitely don't have the best cut ever, and that's why everybody thinks they wants to join us.
Next gen.
But don't you worry.
We'll make sure...
What the?
This rose from the ground.
We'll make sure...
It's not...
Lemons stealing whores that want to join.
That's steal the lemons.
And by lemons, I mean just joining for money.
I think we will...
Strawni and management will have learned a lot from us.
And more...
Have even better ideas of how to pick gen 2.
Not that we were bad picks, that's not what I'm saying.
I'm talking about just like an even more improved interview process.
Am I being attacked?
Okay, bye.
Is this guy gonna run up on me again?
Here he comes.
Mario, your eye is looking in one direction and your other one is looking over here.
Okay, can I follow you?
Watch out.
I'm gonna follow you.
Where are you going?
Come back.
Dude, why are you running away from me?
He just doesn't want to hang out.
Anyways...
Cross-eyed Sam.
He's doing his best.
Yeah, there was more applicants after Strawni.
People are just like, hey, can I join now and be scouted for gen 2?
And Strawni was like, what?
We literally just started, we're not doing gen 2 yet.
But it kind of made me sad.
Because a lot of people didn't want to join or apply as...
Well, not, there was a lot of applicants, don't get me wrong.
But a lot of people didn't think we were going to be successful, so they didn't apply.
They didn't believe in Strawni's vision like me and the other girls did.
So that makes me kind of sad.
But I know that there will be more that see us and it will be like, I want to hang out with them.
You know, I hope so.
Because like, I didn't enjoy thinking I would make any money.
I just want to be a part of it.
I just want to have fun.
Hello?
What's up with your lips?
You look like somebody, you look like a shaw from the UK.
M to the B, M to the B, M, M, M, M to the B, boom.
Excuse me.
Of course, they waited for you to debut and do stuff.
That's only when the entertaining idea of joining you is just as a predicted.
Yeah.
But don't worry about it.
How do you know Blackpool grime? What do you mean?
That was like a famous TikTok sound, bro.
It's all about passion.
Passion for fashion.
And also, I think a lot of people, like another reason why I want people to join are just like having a little bit more talent freedom.
I know that I want like, I don't know if I'll be able to look at applicants or anything or look at their videos or look at their answers, but it'll be really cool too.
Because I would like to say like, see what their reasons are for why.
I bet there will be a lot of repeat people who applied last time.
So that'll be pretty neat.
I have good judgment.
I don't know.
You think I have good judgment?
I don't know what's wrong with you.
The council will define your fate, decide your fate.
You think me having good judgment?
Honestly, I think I act a lot more crazy on stream than I do off stream because I'm actually pretty normal.
More talents means more collab partners.
I judge you guys every day.
I watch a lot of YouTubers.
I do like to creep on a lot of people.
Like, I know there are some people that have expressed interest.
Like, I already, like I've already creeped on them.
They're like, wow, the V alert girls seem really neat.
I would love to join them one day.
And I'm just like, looks at through your content, sees if you're a V tweeter or not.
Reports back to scrawny, like a little, like a little scout.
She be going through every applicant.
Yep.
I want that Gen 4 slime girl.
Come on.
Only best is lobster all places.
Yeah.
My food choices are probably not the best.
But yeah, I would be, where are you from?
Goodbye.
But he looks like a major job.
Does he not?
But I look for, again, we're only three months in.
I don't have to really be thinking about this.
Yeah.
You got to wait till Gen 4.
Does he know?
I don't think he knows.
Can we get a, like a chav, a chav, a chav, a chav is like a, is like a UK gyaru.
Look at the gorse on that nose.
I could sit on it and spam.
The hub.
I call me.
Thanks for nothing.
Sir.
Where's the dude that lives in a tent?
Was that you?
Oh, okay.
I was going to say, oh, there's a lot of people in here.
Mind if I take a nap?
These look like weird.
Oh, I can.
These look like weird burgers.
What kind of model you're begging for?
Shrani and Gen 2 said.
Oh, I already know what Gen 2 is.
I've already said I know what Shrani is cooked up and I've seen some concepts already.
And I've already said that Gen 2 is going to be fucking awesome.
So.
I look like a weird burger.
Is that a woman?
Are you a woman?
I love you.
Oh, yeah, I'm sorry.
I've been sorry.
I've been cooked.
Shrani is already cooked.
It's a wamana.
I got to take a peek sees because I begged because I bother her a lot.
She's a bear, because bunny.
Oh, no.
Cuddle fish.
So, like, if we ever did a thing like guessing Gen 2, I just wouldn't participate because I heard any, no.
know oh yeah no I keep that's like something I would not talk about like I
wouldn't say what they are um I know I bet Strani will give like a lot of like
previews and stuff I was very impressed I'm honestly I'm like can I can I have
like all of those models I would want to be any one of them not that I don't like
myself mind you but I just can't wait to like you guys to see like you're gonna
be like they're so cool and different like you guys don't get it you guys
don't get it like it's actually like they're so unique they're so you like
they're very unique ideas and I'll give credit to Gull where it's do him and
Strani cooked um just changed my voice I am all of Gen 4 um but yeah again that
won't be till next year so sorry boys you gotta wait you gotta wait but I don't
know if the other girls have seen stuff I just again I just bother Strani a lot
so if they I don't know if they've bothered her as well um they can just ask
her and she'll probably show them what is the voice acting this what's your
business I'm here to skate fast and he asked looks like you're doing a shit
job there's only three of you four of you that's the problem
than our Intel initially suggested I'm trying to get some reinforcements here
maybe I have insider info because I see like I know Strani's like my boss but I
see her more as like a friend I see her more as a colleague so I talked to her
pretty I've talked to her almost every morning now and we just chat and she
asked for feedback and I give my honest opinion and I'm not like a yes man or
anything I'll challenge Strani like you guys know like when people when she put
out like the suggestion that we only do one I'm like I think we should do two or
I should be like we should at least be able to do two or one to limit it not
have it be as much as patreon I think that's fine so like I'll push back on
stuff so because the best leaders are people that are acceptance to change and
being challenged and I feel bad because Strani kind of walked back everything
because everybody was being pretty rude and I felt really bad about it because
now she's like do whatever you want I don't want to do like I don't like she
was getting a lot of hate which was kind of a bummer and I was she was only just
giving a suggestion to us a little bit ago the convicts there staged a coup
killed the guards that weren't able to escape but like guys are always we're
allowed to change our minds and stuff so like I know like I know you guys are
like me and like you'll have this expectation you'll be disappointed like
some month I might do only one stream I do too might do not at all maybe some of
the girls won't do any some of them they will and some will not and blah blah blah
so it's like you know yeah and I I do have to say I definitely had to do with
like a lot of the brain worms people had in the audience cuz like on our side we
were like okay like it's everything's fine blah blah blah blah and this is what
I meant when I said before like sometimes we'll say something over text and then
people will take it and kind of like run with their own idea of what's
happening and I really wish you guys would kind of just like wait for a
stream or just like ask nicely cuz like all we want is to make you guys happy
and be nice but if if you guys are rudely questioning things then it makes
us harder makes it harder for us to communicate properly because like me
and Mercy and Shawnee and in me and in Icy and Azura um we all communicated fine
about it like what we were gonna do and not do and whatever and I think people
just got a little worried um yeah like please please I like if you don't like
something I beg of you please be kind like we're still learning we're still
growing as a company Shawnee's never run a Vtuber agency before and does like
she's very business minded and she wants what best she wants what's best for
everybody in the company at the same time it's a fine line to manage um but
please don't like I'm actually getting kind of like sad almost crying right
now cuz it was really hard to hear like it gets so worked up but she didn't want
to make anybody mad or anything cuz you don't know how much she does for all of
us um and I think it like stressed Mercy out a lot and that's why she deleted
her stuff cuz like I think it was just a little bit overwhelming people's
responses and it didn't need to be it was honestly like big enough a bigger
thing of a hullabaloo about nothing you know and you know I like and people can
understand something one way and people can understand another way and if it's
up to them how they interpret it but you have to accept like again maybe we need
to be better at communicating with you guys and I apologize for that um it was
it was really hard seeing a lot of stuff the people said about everybody it still
is I don't care if people shit on me I generally don't but when you shit on my
gen mates it's hard cuz you people don't know how wonderful they are and they
assumed a lot of stuff behind the scenes
like they're all very sweet and they want the best for everyone just please
trust us just please yes believe in us just give us give us a grace please
just give us a little bit of grace if if something if like if like Amy uses
her voice differently or or if I see you wants to do like a like just try
something out like we're just trying to come up with ways to entertain you guys
we're not trying to hurt anybody or make anybody upset we want to make you happy
it's like it's so funny like I'll just read like really harsh things about
myself but I won't give a shit but if I read harsh things about my gen mates it
makes me sad because I my gen mates are like the kindest people I've ever met
they only want what's best for us the company and for each other and for you
guys you have to trust us okay also sorry if you just came here for new Vegas
stuff or whatever or like for my Elden Street ring streams that totally didn't
but did have but didn't happen earlier just a little just like they just got a
lot of like blowback for us like not wanting to do as many fans these
streams that's that's just like TLDR and people kind of took things of course a
lot of people are just trolling like doll like there's trolling but then there
is just like people who I knew like just genuinely were shit heads um mama is
qui um yeah I care a lot for you guys I also hate seeing you guys upset and when
you guys are like sad or mad about something or like I'm like I'm like I'm
like I try to set the record straight as gently and kindly as I can um
God save the queen
you're all queese bon kwee kwee um but yeah that's all I ask of you cuz we care
about you and we want to have fun and we also like want to try new things you
know I think a lot of pressure is put on us to be at one way or the other and I
honestly you guys will have the best experience if you let us entertain you
in try new projects and try new stuff out and try new avenues and try to figure
ourselves out let that let us cook because when you let us cook it will be a
lot happier and we'll want to make the best content for you and that's why I
like I'm very thankful you guys let me dress up in different outfits because
honestly my last fan base hated that I like I dressed up in different outfits
and I was sometimes would change my model and I was my PL and people just
kept shitting on me constantly and but I I like that I can express myself here
um and then because of that you get the keynote streams like yesterday of me
just fucking around as a noodle playing retro doob
but yeah I just wanted to be kind of real for a second as we stare at this
man in the face um again I'm sorry for making it like this I don't know why it's
just kind of popped into my head and I probably shouldn't have even acknowledged
anything because sometimes that just perpetuates the issue but you know what
I've already said it so what can you do I have a big mouth I like to yeah what a
frick is my I wish I could like purposely kill a tomagotchi can I murder a
tomagotchi is that like can I just like send it to the kill shelter because
you're so ugly he looks like a piece of poop yeah but then I know like people
take stuff that I say and they'll clip it and they'll put it places out of
context looking at you staring oh thank you grim sage for the 20
please say thank you if you were gifted please say thank you thank you so much
grim sage absolute dubs um yeah I don't know how it did I was uh hope that
doesn't fucking bite me in the ass ah because it's reaching outside of my
sphere awkward that's what happens when you talk about stuff that has nothing to
do with you ladies and gentlemen I just wanted to say my peace invented my my
stream that totally didn't happen today before this one um don't don't don't say
it why would you say it mods kill him
kill him now
for like 10 seconds no okay my mods aren't here it's fine don't worry about it
um
do you have any information not much they've taken to calling themselves
powder gangers mostly because they've taken to using the explosives meant to
clear boulders as weapons they got organized faster than I would have
thought most of them at least thankfully I don't care
uh okay ma'am
ma'am can I take your gun uh
I don't think that's how you get out of a chair
don't look at me like that don't look at me like a skyrim mpc
don't don't don't do that this is really unsettling
so I feel like I'm just playing reskins modded skyrim
can I go in here and steal anything
oh these are nicer things I can steal some open oh
what happens if I steal these
then I do that do they come for me do they make a quicksave let's do it
is there a quicksave thingy it's not climb unless I get caught so if I
crouch I'm hidden okay it's fine
do I need these
make a conductor I don't know what that is but it's worth more
okay I don't know I'm here it's empty
I'll take some scrap I've lost karma
what does that mean
it's not important I'm evil now
if I walk out wearing everything will they notice
okay
karma I lost aura what the hell is aura
stole what does that mean
what's a death claw all right
see it's fine they didn't notice a damn thing later nerds so like what do I
need to do
inquire about my delivery assignment with the ministry of the mojave express
and prim so do I have to kill them
okay let me let me dress up let me go up here and dress up a little oh wait
actually what is this missile
there's no rocket launcher here oh is that dude
um
probably follow my death let's uh
oh
faction armor oh
okay
what's the difference this one's better can I have a trooper helmet
how do I look
oh nifty
can I sneak around this guy
oh he doesn't seem to care okay cool
I don't see what those things are mines welcome to my mine
your enemies stumbled upon image channel sorry streaming hope you're having
awesome day night aura check where what is how do I check my aura
my aura my my
how do I check that how do I check my
aura aura aura somewhere under status
let me
data
the fuck was that noise let's take out the gun
that's not the take out the gun I am the one don't need a gun and I respect the
pun me so they're down there so I'll loop around
this way
under general I uh okay
gen gen oh
uh is this an alphabetical order
what items crafted total things killed
I think you're incorrect
it's scrolling the chat that's so weird what I'm trying to scroll here
I can steal them
neutral means I'm not evil oh but I want to be evil
evil me my mom went to a costume party we
draw stuff as my mermaid man and barnacle boy
I was mermaid man I painted a purple starfish on my face
oh he's running at me
uh why is is he gonna swee say it all me
do I just have to keep doing this
ah
ow
oh
ow I forgot to select it how are you still alive
can you stop
crippled did you just I don't I shoot him in the dick
you're I just shot you in the head that doesn't make any sense can I steal your
stuff
ooh dressed up as him
hold on we're gonna we're gonna sneak in
ow
okay actually I kind of want to do goggles helmet
yeah oh no I'm one of you
oh okay whatever
oh my god let's just shoot you in the body does that mean I miss
why does he get to hit me
I don't know what's this thing that's I can shoot him in the leg
what does a low AP mean
oh well I might die
okay
low action points
so I can only do it so many times
all right oh yeah I like it a lot oh I need to aim down sights up
what is happening
all right what the f**kings can I stop looking at him what the f**k was that
all right um
all right I think I should probably do
okay what else do you got on you oh thank you I have a cleaver merc charmer
how much can I carry
nice nice what do you mean the crimes I've committed
I haven't committed any crimes I can be a charmer I can be a veteran
that's fine what does your helmet look like your helmet's stupid I don't like it
how am I supposed to get to this person if these conflicts are everywhere I don't
just kidding when I say conflicts are everywhere I mean only two
are they in there
oh okay
would be a shame if someone shot me in the head right now
not that can see you look like you're covered in blood
Jonathan Nash
um want to play a hand what the f**k is caravan who are you
okay
I'll tell you whatever
oh you're talking about one of
well now that you mentioned it sorry I'm speed reading one of the townies was out
I have a deck I have a dick right here I can't see but I flopped my arm on the table
great call about a chip a chip
well for that your best since they came to town he may have heard where they would go
that cowboy robot had as high as six couriers each was carrying something a little different
weird dice chest piece that kind of stuff like last victim of the robot it looked like payment
had been received for the other five jobs first deadbeat we hired to do the job cancelled
no different fella bigger had himself a face
what the I guess do you mean victor hired us
I guess a beagle had some no
so
Jesus f**k I can buy just a seven of hearts
I had the last package
tales of sheevlar
I can buy vodka vodka my tolerance goes down
I'm sorry I'm scrolling a bunch because the chat is scrolling on the other
my other monitor what the hell just fell the tomagotchi how do they get over there
there's so much cat here on my f**king keyboard hello
I didn't clean my keyboard desperately holy crap
I can eat some iguana
cowboy repeater that's a bladed gump what the f**k
oh cool
sorry I can't see what you guys are saying because the page is now scrolling instead of the chat
now scroll all the way down
all right whatever
wait did I buy anything did I have to accept oh my god
I did okay hold on I wanted I don't know what energy cells do
um
kind of like like like 20
okay and then I don't want the water and then I want that stem pack
I kind of want this bladed gump
I want
except
now what
no I don't want to cancel the transact guys how do I pay I can't see what you guys are saying
the chat is scrolled down I don't have the money I thought I have 568 caps or is that his caps
oh I only have 68
whoopsies
can I steal from him
can I steal and take his body
yeah
nah I want to get the con with if they had a caravan
just kidding that's not what I said gangers
you think you have what it takes kid
why is my gun out
you're gonna wait bro who else am I supposed to talk what the hell are you
who am I supposed to talk to you
hello there what brings you to prim um thank you calls for the super
my mother taught me never it's okay see you what do you play in fucking the slots
do I still have to talk to him who who is this pointy yet
okay
I have to go in there
she exit leave me alone
why do I have to buy cars hello there's enemies in here
wait I think I have a better pistol these holds
I can make weapons
boom I'll take the 10 millimeter I don't know how many animals I have 25
oh
I think he's dead I think I got him
do you have any bullets
no I might have to switch to the nine millimeter
do you have dirty water why do you have dynamite
what can I do with this I'm gonna take it
oh give me your fucking money give me your fucking money what is the jet
what's the jet
the jet is a drug weird
hold on I can't reload please hold there's a game pause when I'm like this
seems like it does
oh
nifty you have anything
I love killing and blowing heads off I'm gonna blow you so hard you're not gonna know what hit you
oh it's like I'm taking coins and scarring I don't know what I just took
I wasn't paying attention I was pointing at the caps
um can I read a book
I need books to read to get some skizzles
sasperilla oh what this nothing hey what does this sasperilla do
I'll take that
I need a lockpick skill of 75 is there can I hack can I hack the game
how do I hack the game
I grabbed a paperweight well maybe I can sell it
can I is there like a console I can just give myself stuff
no I don't fucking care about hacking computers
pre-war money it's like a five dollar bill
what just happened oh how do I give myself money I mean how do I give myself lockpicking skill
what's the code is it do I type in mother load
I don't weigh anything take them
loads of money of money that's not gonna work
I'm not gonna play the game give me the freaking pickpocket cheat or I'm gonna google it myself
that's the only thing I ever cheat on in games is the pickpocket skill
okay it looks like I'm googling it since you guys want to be little brats
uh pick lockpick skill cheat
follow new Vegas console command
hello
What
He can't stop me you can't stop me. Oh, I can't do control V never mind. I'll have to type it in manually
When you capitalize
I
Did I do it did I do it
Did I do it
I
Have it
I got rated again hello, hello
Amaraka ya
You did tingles and everybody tingled. Oh
Tingly I just I'm
Where are my arms?
They're they're they're down my arms are down. I
Can show you what I'm wearing
What do you mean where are my arms I can't even open a vtube studio with you right here
Not my head's big don't worry about oh my shirts messed up hold on hold on my shirts messed up
Why did nobody tell me that my shirt has been messed up this entire time
Why didn't any of you tell me I'm not cheating
I'm not cheating
Wasd
Wait what
I
Know
Don't know what that means
What does a cigarette do
I
Get lucky
What's the case I don't know what that means I
Have to sign 13 skill points what the fuck
I
Have high sell value. Oh
Cases or bullet case you can make your own bullets. Oh interesting speech
Boss call and 70 years ago. Wow, that's crazy. How did I get to a hundred? I don't know
No
Yeah
Choose one perk oh cannibal. Oh, I want to be a cannibal
Don't ask
Sure, so la fam I can do 10% damage against female combats. Oh, I can be I can just be a gay femme fatale
Does this mean I can fuck people I
Want why can't I eat people
Holy shit, all these are level 10. That's why oh disappointing
Yeah, I
I need more levels there's more. Yeah, there's more men in the game. So I'm gonna do black widow. I'm a black widow, baby
Isn't that how the lyrics go
Pop up up
babe, I
Fought the law in the law one. I fought the law in the long one. I
Need some money cuz uh, hello
I fought the law in the law. I only have
Can I inspect it like I'm in fucking CS
Yippie yippie kye mother fuckers
Who wants fuck you want some fuck
You want some fuck
I'll give you some fuck
I missed
Don't fucking run
What are you what are you doing
This is a pretty gun
What what um, take me close. Uh, what?
Is that temporary is buff out temporary
Assuming so
I
Understandable
Oh, I was gonna shoot them. Hey
I'm not trying to pick pocket you. Hey, I don't suppose you came here to rescue me
I'd cross my fingers, but my hands are numb. You have weird teeth
Why yes, I am it's a pleasure to meet you likewise. I'm in a bit of a predicament here
I'd be most appreciative if you'd set me free only if you'll give me a
Only if you
We all got a
Let me stop talking
Oh, I should know I should have made my demands probably afterwards
All right, it's a lot of exposition, uh, here you go
Uh
You don't stick with me
I should shoot you in the fucking head, how about that?
Can I
How many where is there egg timer?
I don't know what this money does I am just taking it because how might what are the rounds is it magnum rounds?
What did you guys tell me?
Happy to my models arms. What are you guys talking about?
Guys
I
I my arms are down here
I have a big head my arms are down here
I'm not a nug yet
I
Stop saying I'm a nugget. I'm not a nugget
Wait, was that matt marcer the voice? Oh, maybe it was it did kind of sound like him now. I think of it
I'm a I'm not a nugget. I have hands
Stop calling me nuggy
That's not very
Um
He just called me a what?
Mods
I
Caught off his pee pee and feed it to Cheyenne
Have to pick my wedge
My bra strap is falling down
Well, let's talk. What does this have? Oh
That's it
Okay, bye
Wait a second. That's not supposed to happen
Hell hell not frozen, okay
Leave me alone
I'm being bullied
I'm being bullied. I can't see where I am. Okay. I'm enough off to the side
Decapitation no breathing
Oh
Okay, uh, I don't have enough of the
Oh, I don't have enough of the thingy
What the fuck how am I actually nasty?
Oh
Um
Do you think they're okay can I?
Hold on I'm busy. I'm just gonna take this
I I'm gonna die. Hold on. I'm trying to change my fucking weapon. These guys are shooting me
Hold on I should probably have a stimpak. Oh, yeah, don't come in yet. I'm busy
Jesus fuck
That's pretty hot I'll take that
Flamer
Am I gonna set dudes on fire?
Ah
Who wants some who wants some do you
I should probably be taking the bobby pins
Bottle caps
No
I got this skill am I going the right way?
Oh, what that
Luca cola
Oh, no, thank you
I'm okay with that. I don't want radiation
It's pointing me outside
Hmm. This is not outside
What that
It is yeah, okay, what's upstairs though?
Oh, it's saving for me
Oh
It's empty I should have read that it's a wonder glue
Doctors bag, hmm
What's mentats
Like Xanax what that a vacuum cleaner
I'm creeping
I do actually I like that a lot
I'll take that squirrel on a stick don't mind if I do
Nothing over here danger
I don't know you tell me
Oh
Drugs drugs you'll like that you'll like that I do it turns me on seeing your bodies combust into flames
I love looting bodies and fucking hotties
What that didn't apply
Anybody I don't want to drink from the toilet
What a burn hello
Oh
Okay, I'll go up there in a second
See if there's anything down here
Oh, looks like this is just another way up
Perhaps
Pre-war relaxed wear
I want that. Yeah, I want that. Wait, did I accidentally put something inside? Okay, I did
You
Maybe you are just jumpy
No, stay on fire. Oh, you're not on fire the other guy is though. Anyways
What was what?
How are they not dead?
Oh, I think he's dead if somebody ragged all in awkwardly behind the door
Oh
I love bugs and games
Anyways
Dog me that's terrible
The doggy mask
What where are you dude?
Where are you?
Am I blind? Oh
Yeah, maybe you are just jumpy
Hey is for horses not for cows pinks don't eat them because they don't know how
Yeah, I know dog meat from follow for yippie
Ant meat I don't like the sound of that
So first impact the buff. Oh, okay
Did I get everything in here
Oh
Yeah, that's how it's done perfume bottles. No, I don't know where to go
I think that's it. Oh, yeah, I think I think that's it
Did I kill them all
Oh
Well, I didn't walk further down actually
Or did I I um I did I came this way it's fine
Wait did I go
All these rooms look the same
I
Think he's okay
Jet what does AP mean?
That's a lot of drugs cycle cycle
Oh, no, what's happened? Oh
Take a switch
Hello
I took the switchblade. I'm sorry you were what's medx
I'll just sell some drugs so I'll just become a drug dealer
AP is action points all I see
I see I feel like did it was able to get over there. Oh, yeah, I killed those guys
Yeah, baby
My tummy inches
Bye bye
Have fun
All right
Let me out
I killed all these men now what
I love lockpicking
Oh, I could take an astrate. Oh, I wonder if I can get in there
Hello
I'm not taking any radiation pistol
Oh
What
Take a lunchbox
I
Nifty
Can I force it
And even them
Weapon spread reduced
Oh damage resistance
I guess I'll take the drugs
I'm so mad. I'm just gifted
Hello
Hey
No
Hold on my go XLR got fucking again. I got pee
Mute to fart
You
Hold on I have to close out the go XLR
And then open it again
I
Fix my
Okay, is it working? Can you hear me?
Can you dig it I need her
Are my eyes so fucking
I got some big old eyes and tick old bitters. I'm done. Okay
Auto tune she be
I don't know any Jason Derulo songs
Can sing shunkings
That's why it'll never work. You have me sweet say doll
Sweet say doll when you say it's
Damn all these
It's
The only one the louis and norton won't actually know I take that back. That's not
That's not really true
I'm trying to think of a song I can sing to you
Um
Let me
Let me think of a song
D pain
Oh, baby
Talk talk. There we do me
Swallow I don't know that glad you I don't know these songs
At the bar tender
Look at me. I'm at the bar with her
Actually
It actually works. I don't know that song
Doesn't really make sense either
You just sounds like you just sound like a freeloader. That's not accurate. I'm on a boat
I'm on a boat
And I just in my pants. Oh hi rena. She's talking about my my my lap. I don't mean to hurt you
Harley you should let me love you. Let me be the one to
Give you everything you want and need
Something something something something
Give you interaction
Tell you the way love's supposed to be
Baby you should love me
Yeah, that's how it goes, right
I
I don't know Spanish
That actually really worked
Reena, what are you doing? I don't know that song by rick aigles. Yes
Something something box something something in the box
Huh
I'm trying to think of love songs, but all I can think of is the pressing songs
I
Was a baby oh
If I was your boyfriend, I'd never let you go. I could take you places you ain't never been before
Baby take a chance
I got money in my hand. So they really like to blow swag swag swag on you
Chilling by the fire while we eat fondue. I don't know about me, but I know about you say the hello to visitor in three two swag
To be anything you want
Herum
Let me talk to you if I was your she be I never let you go
Keep you on my arm boy never be alone
And I could be a girlfriend
Anything you want. Yeah, if I was your she be I never let you go
Yeah, does that work?
Boomi, can you guys get off of my desk, please? Sorry it's my cats
Who let the cats out?
Boomi just got scared by the microphone
You want to say so
Didn't even know there's a bunches that you're all with
We've got to keep it focused you want to say so
You think I can sing the moccureno
You got that
Cuz you got that
Cuz you got that. I like you but I need that something that you need something something
So give it to me cuz you got that
I actually really like that song. It's kind of a bop
I
Need a bucket and a mop or some raw-ass chicken
And wait, I actually know a lot of the pump the punk goes pop versions of songs because they almost
Saying like the chasing haley chasing holly. I don't know that song
I like that version
Oh
I was telling
The v alert girls in our meeting. I want to cover wop as a group
And you can just have me in the background going there's some hoes in this house
There's some hoes in this house in this and then you just hear I see
Startle fries freak seven days a week white ass pussy and make this plot game weak
Huh, and then you just have like any you're fucking with some wet ass pussy get a bucket and a mop for this
And then like a zero give me everything you got and I can't do this for this one ass pussy
Give me everything you got for this wet ass
Beat it up baby catch a charge extra large and extra hard
Johnny put this pussy right in our face swiper knows like a credit card
I
Then mercy hop I can't ever do mercy's place just be like
Hop on top. I want to ride. I'll do a kiko while it's inside
What do we need to do
There's some hoes in this house
Get a bucket and a mop for this viewer pussy
Give you everything you got for this viewer pussy
There's some hoes in this house there's some hoes
Are like what's the other card of your song?
Oh
I said my face bomb ass tight racks that come shack high give me human right
I've been doing some last night. Give me what the good good make everything
Both girls don't order right now
Broke boys don't know what no pussy don't get no pussy. I know that's right. I don't know the lyrics
Chat could be the background dancers
Well, I'll cover well you guys have to ask scrawny
You guys have to ask
Hold on. Yeah, if I keep singing I'm this is gonna turn to a karaoke stream. You know how I get
Anyway, hold on
I think you need a new one
I can see the way I see the way you look at me and even when you look away, I know you think of me
I know you talk about me all the time. I can't it again
So come over here. Tell me what I want to hear better yet. Make your girlfriend disappear
Make your oh she disappear. I don't want to see her face over again
Hey
You guys can't see how much I'm gesturing now a song we all learned to spell bananas too
Few times I've been around that track and it's not gonna happen like that because we're in no hollow back girl
in no hollow back girl
Um
Oh me are you okay? What happened?
I need to check on my cats
Gossip folks is good
I think I might do a parody song of that
No, I'd get so much shit in the community for that
of uh, I could be your oh she
And all
The harem are the harlots say I'm pretty fly for a brown girl
Yeah, she's getting a tattoo down. She's getting ink done. She asked for a 13 and they drew her 31
Sorry
I
Autotuned burp. Can I can I fart an auto tune? I can't fart right now. Yeah, boomie's fine
But where's rena?
She is fine
Are you good? What are you doing?
She was standing there
Are you behaving?
Hi
Why are you walking like that? Are you trying to seduce me?
My cats always have like a little sway walk when they want to be pet
Biracial by Sean I don't know who that is
Not only a biracial song is that one me my song tick tock and it's this guy singing
She's biracial
She's biracial girl. That's all I remember. Is that that song?
And I don't like your oh, she's song and the reeflings. Yeah, no, but it'd be a remix of all of us
It would be all the other people
Turns out the bridesmaid was a vealer member
I time in with the haven't you people ever heard of
Close. Okay. I need to stop
We're stopping we're stopping
Stop
It is that song. Oh my god, I never do the name or the artist. I only saw like that one clip. That's so funny. Okay
Just another manic Monday, what's a doctor's bag do or store all body parts?
Um
Like you just away
I'm never doing but another webkins. I always think he says webkins. You don't have me read the way
I don't need the cheese or my car keys boy. Like you just go away
Stop stop stop making me sing more stop
Are playing the game
I'm changing my weapon. What the fuck
Are you gonna light this up
Where's the game sound
What
Where's maintenance key
I can't hear the game I can't
Hell
How many TVs are away the rest of my dad
Looking away
I don't know what to say. I'll say it anyway
Never to find you
I go away
I'll be coming for you. I'm okay
Take on me
You take on me take me
I'll be gone
In a day or two
Okay
Sing more by oh, okay
You clicked outside to fool around the youtube studio. What do you mean?
Hello, all righty the fucking tango then did I kill them all?
Is there more
Why is this music so loud
Can I search through the dumpster can I be a little dumpster rat diver? No, okay
Can you guys hear the game
Oh
Open to come dumpster
Okay, cool. What's all this enemy I want to kill him
Where is he at he's shooting at me
But like from where
Was it a bug I don't
I don't even it's not even on my thing anymore
Oh, he's up there. What the fuck are you doing bro?
I'm gonna get you. I'm gonna get you
I can't shoot. I have the wrong gun. Please hold
Uh, do you have any? No, I'm almost dead
He didn't say I can only hear the gate. I can't hear anything else besides the background music
Yeah, why is there only game music and no sound?
Oops, hold on
What the hell
Why can't I save
Okay
I guess the game bugged I guess I suppose so. Yep
That's weird
Um
Do I go talk to them now I pursue assume so we'll never know what they're saying
Hey
Well, that was quite an adventure. We taught those convicts a thing or two, didn't we?
Breaking myself out of a hostage situation not to diminish your role in it, of course, but it was quite thrilling. Can I kill him?
Problem is there's still no law and pram. What do we do next time ruffians menace us and hold his hostage?
I
Or are the qualifications for sheriff
I don't have to fucking time they didn't shoot the deputy
I shot the sheriff
I
Can I shoot him
I'm dead I'm gonna restart the game anyways
Bigger bigger hat
I just made myself bigger
Am I neighbor screaming?
I feel like I can hear my neighbor screaming it, but I don't know if I'm the lulu
I think I got smaller last time so I'm gonna make it a little bit bigger. There we go
I think it like it scrolled down for some reason
You want a smaller hat
Model smaller hat bigger guys. I'm not gonna die that much
You
Well, I did say I saved before I went in
So it's fine
Sexy oh there we go
Oh
The tops dropping up and down on and on hey there
Well
Your sheriff
I know what it's like if you run across someone who's bearing okay
I can't kill the deputy I suppose who else do I have to talk to in here? I should probably put my gun away
Sorry my cats are playing. Why do you slide your gun out? Is it you? Do I still have to talk to him? I do
It should be
You will the sheriff that was incarcerated up it. Okay
I still have to talk to you
Stop leaving. You're not finding a suit. No, I'm still looking. Ah, yeah, I was good. They were talking about something. They said
Thank you
Howdy
I know I was trying to
I was trying to ask him
Who put the muffins in the freezer? I did what you're gonna do about it. Wait, what?
Jesus Christmas
All right, well wait
Well, it's
All right had a Novak through tipped in
I should probably buy some stimpaks from this guy. Yep. Ah, yep
As I are a weapon or hall then are you as glad why do you just have a gun out?
Where is
You guys is all walking around you guys just walking around with their guns out or like that's kind of
Oh, what this? Oh, I can't open it. There's bitches around
Where is the guy
Beagle oh there. Hey youngster still hanging about prim, huh? I am sir. Um
Prim slim, but I just want to buy some
Okay, I have 177 caps
I can get some Magnum rounds and I'll do that in a moment
That's tops
What are you doing boomy boomy just slammed the cat tree against the window my neighbor's probably fucking hate me
The fact I haven't gone in a noise complaint yet is a miracle. I'm probably gonna get one later
And can I get some
Oh
Okay, can I sell you stuff
Do I need these
I
Need those
No, it's just for trading perfect
Give me all of your money you want to bent in can
And
Thank you buy some more rounds
Oops
Or maybe not any more stems
I
Just have corn
I guess I'll get the manual
Wait did I just buy knows it but it's okay
Sick
I have to pee I need to get going I got a pee I also need a fucking heel
Okay
Yep
Howdy
Already wore off goddamn
Did I accidentally drink something
Didn't need the rat away did I accidentally drink the rat away
Oh, I did
Oh, I didn't mean to
That sucks I was saving that just in case
Um
All right time to walk hold on I need to pee
Let me go piss
Yep best time
So
Tee he I'm laughing so hard
Oh
This isn't a beach it's a toilet
Shibidi toilet scatter what are y'all doing? I only need to stretch
Check on field
Oh
Sorry I'm googling because
You know how we were talking about stuff leaving the sphere of when I was streaming this morning
so
I checked my maros. Well, I was sitting on the toilet, you know to tune away
Oh, baby containment breach. Oh, they found me. It's your bow
They're after me the fans it's fine
I just think it's people funny people thought I deleted the vaude because
um
Because of what I said, no
I can say it again right now
Um, but again, it's not really any of my business. So I shouldn't really have spoken on it. I was just raging. Um
I just deleted the vaude because I fucking went mental
Over not getting food. I wanted and I didn't want people to see
Uh
Is a full schizo's it's a smattering
But then it's some people going nice
And I'm like, okay. I wasn't trying to win brownie points. I was just stating my opinion
um, I literally just didn't want people to see me fucking
Hear me fucking flip out tyler one style. I'm not getting my door dash
um
Hi mari, but I'll say it again because I ain't no bitch. All right
Don't get it twisted. No sure that nah nah nah she be stop it she be
Stop it down
Down go don't get baited
That's bait. You can't see I'm doing the I'm doing the I'm doing the I'm doing the the mad max looking up. That's bait. I can't do it
Don't get don't get baited. I'm not getting baited. You like my boobs. I'm jiggling them right now. You can't see
It's me slapping my tits together
I'm not getting baited. I'm not you're not gonna have me
Jesus
You know if somebody said in my marrow, they're like, can you stop spamming
Can you stop spamming the lovely basket weaving forums and I'm like with your with your shitty
Shitty clips you piece of fucking shit bitch and I'm like
brother
I didn't make no clips brother
I'm fucking streaming the
I'm just sitting here poorly playing
poorly playing
This is a chilies. Hi. Welcome to chilies
Why oh nobody's being it's it's not nobody's being mean people are just mad everybody's angry. Nobody loves each other
Where is the love the love the love, you know
I'm just a bunny girl, man. This is this isn't the beach. This is a bathtub
Why are they mad?
They're mad because I spoke the truth
Vtubers shouldn't vtubers crying vtubers hurt
Them rats are dying
Will you practice what you preach or will you turn in vtweet?
No, hold on
Help us send some guidance from above because people got me got me questioning
Where is the love?
I don't know this is controversial
It's not really like I'm not getting like I'm not outing anybody. I was just saying how it irritated me
That's it. Um
I never talked to the vtuber about it that was involved or any of them. I just I just an observant. I just observed it
um
I just spoke about an observation what I'm realizing now is that because I have a bigger platform
Then when I was like a two view nobody people take what I say and they think I'm making like some sort of statement
I was just I was just saying an observation and saying that I was irritated. It's not saying my opinion
Yeah, I know it wasn't asked. Nobody asked. I know
But I was just on my stream wanting to talk. Okay
Speak your truth sis
speak your truth
um
Mahalo might come after me, but it's fine. It's okay. I'll be fine. It's okay. Don't worry about it
It's cool. It'll die down in like a day somebody will fucking yeah
And I will sit here reminding my business and shutting the fuck up staying in my lane flourishing fiving
Everything is just so literal
Oh, the stamp pack finally wore off
Uh, it'll not come after you. I don't know. Niji did once
but that was on my pl and I was a nobody and they just kept shitting on me because
I said something about being worried
Hello
Oh, they're shooting me up there. What the fuck? Oh, I don't have a gun out
Don't shoot me. I just healed bro. I just healed
I missed
I'm just shooting in a circle and holding for the best
Sometimes he's hit
If I just spam and I just aim in a general direction
Where is he? Did I kill him? I don't know
Do you not you know she is the one
Yeah, but then you you have fans of them
You have fans. That's what I mean the fans
Fans of make her dance
All these shit popping pussy. I'm just popping man. Man. I'd rather be
flamed for like flesh posting than
Me just saying some people are annoying and should somebody should apologize. Well, apparently the person was fine with it. So, okay
I think they I'm not gonna talk about anymore though
Is she sniping with the pistol? Yeah, brother
What is that
Is this a horror game what's up with the fucking music wait, what why is the radiation
What the fuck I just walked over some rocks. I don't understand
What's that is it a sheep the sheep are friendly, right?
They're friendly sheep they won't hurt me, right?
Yeah, I just can't shut up. That's why
Is this sheep friendly?
Hi sheep
Hello, they're not friendly
They're not friendly
He was not happy that one was not domesticated
I'm breathing in the chemicals
You know, it wasn't okay. No shut up she be shut up shut up shut up shut up stop talking just play the game
Uh, I just want to kill people. What's up with that?
Is there any enemies here? I just want to shoot guys heads off
I've discovered nipples. Oh nipton
Yo, there's a lot of people's here. I gotta turn this way
What's that holler? Oh
What happened to Owen
What why did the thing just do dots? What happened to baru?
Oh, oh my god, it's uncle Owen and Aunt Barra
No, why would they have this as a reference? That's so fucked bro
Because I was like wait that sounds familiar because it's fucking Star Wars
I
Where am I going?
Okay, I'm close. Oh, what's the question I'm on right now?
Ask her on Novak. Okay, let's do it
That I sorry I was looking at the chat so I just ran into that point blank
Novak
No, what?
Are they up there? I I am assuming I will loop around
Are you are you kidding me that I don't have some sort of mount
not even like
Like a little little like can I get like a scooter?
Do they have razor scooters?
Oh
I was there a mine there
Welcome to my mine. Is that a dude I can shoot? It is indeed
I need to reload
Oh, what the fuck how did you get over here?
I need to hold on
Ow
How are you still alive? Oh my god, please hold. I need to switch my weapon
Oh
Please hold
Ow. Oh, she blew up
Ow
What are you
Zero percent. Okay, then why would I try?
I can't mess the notification. Let me some new bang as a favorite nobody I know most of my family. I hope you
DLC install for it. Nope. I am completely vanilla
Too high a level mad at my limbs. What about my limbs? What about my limbs?
Oh, I have one health
Okay
They use it
Ah
How could this happen to me
I made my mistake
Hey, um, was I running on my kneecaps? I need a bigger hat
I need a bigger hat
I hate it. I hate it here. I was kidding. No, that's what I don't hate
Oh
Yep, hey, hey, hi, hey
And let me check this code
Oh
Hold on sorry, Niana sent me something funny
I like having my friends just send me memes
So
Excited for the collab tomorrow
I have a collab tomorrow. Oh, yeah, I have a collab in neon tomorrow. Yeah
I I don't know where I am half the time. I'll I'll be real with you. I I generally don't know
I don't keep track of anything I fucking do
I'm like, what the hell are you talking? I've just been living breathing and smelling
You
What was that
Um
Okay
All right
That's pretty pretty fire beat. Hold on. Hold on. Let me see if I can rap to it
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I can't just kidding. I can you think I can freestyle? No
No way I can parody a song in five seconds, but I cannot freestyle. Okay. Where is this motherfucker? He's gonna shoot me
My gun isn't out
Think I'm hitting him like that
All right sick nasty, bro. Yeah, I'm good at fps is
Against people not so much
I
Free rifle I already have that rifle, don't I?
What is that what is that are they hugging?
I
Kind of want to go over there
What the hell my chat fucked up again, please. Oh my god, please please
Why does it fuck up this scroll? I just can't
I
Yes, it still counts shut up you shut your little whore mouth. Okay
Broke back mountain
Cool
Oh, look it's a little scalpel
It's a little scalpel, bro
It's a little scorpion mouth
He's just a little guy it literally
How do I level three from walking?
All right, let's do sneak
Let's do crazy how I already have that let's do gun
Let's do
Yeah, I don't know why what I'm applying to what I just oh
I see
I get points
Oh my god, I'm really gonna cry if I have to walk all the way. You know, maybe I should save
I can't believe you have a thousand saves what happens if you go past a thousand saves does it start overriding them?
Hello, that's a big buggy
Look, it's a little race track. We can race buggies
Do you want to race?
Oh, we can race car you tell me I can't drive that come on
Am I
What is that rumbling noise outside? I thought it was in game for a second. I was confused
It deletes everything what is up with the music? Oh
And you just wait can I oh
Aunt meat
Oh thank you
Oh no
Oh, I thought I was walking on water, but I'm like and that wouldn't really make any sense for this
Everybody over here. Oh, this isn't safe
This is not safe. This is not safe
Happy I saved so I don't have to run all this way again
Why there's so many mad mean people I'm just trying to
Go the wrong way, you know, they're shooting me
No, it's not the cats
Oh that bird scared me
What are you doing?
I'm just trying to do stuff. Oh, give me that
It's a banana you go
I don't want no trouble. Don't worry about it
You
Soundtrack is fascinating
Oh, it's a blue scorpion. You think it's nicer blue means good, right?
Oh
What the fuck where did you come from?
That just scared me so bad
I just scared me so bad
I didn't do a bigger hat
All right
I just
I don't know where
Maybe the long I'm just trying to live my life. Oh my god, it's clipping through my camera
What is that is that the anthill? Oh, can I go I don't think I want to go in there
Don't worry, I'm just I'm just passing through you don't have to worry about me
Don't worry miss mr. Ants
Mr. Anderson
Can I save?
I can't say I can't say with this open
Um accidentally press the tilt instead of the escape, but I'm kind of scared to unpress it
You know that remember like um
Pt silent hill anytime someone's like behind you. I just think of the guy that's like
Look behind you
I want to you really want to do this bro
She thinks he's good
A game that never was I know right are they making a silent hill can I I'm hidden I can't see me about to live this man's body
Are they all just I'm detected gonna get myself gonna get myself detected
I'm trying to go blind from the light that is reflected
Is there a quick save button like Skyrim
They hate Kojima
What's the quick save button
Don't say f5
Oh, what the fuck didn't you you just say yes, but you don't tell me what it is. You're like, yeah
Say yes, it is blank
I don't know why I just smelled I just smelled feet
I just got this cheesy smell
Is boomy nearby
Hello, can I sneak in yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah, okay, that's not working
Is that the dead dragon and Elden Ring?
Alt f4 like you guys think I'm an idiot
What that
Echo
I
Let's got P napple. Tell me I can't eat that
I like is it gee how am I supposed to get up there? Oh
I'm going in the wrong direction
Okay, that one fucking key
All right
Because I
Feel like
I'm a little confused. This is where I died before or near
Does it really want me just to go into nipton before I can go to the next part?
What's up with the fucking music?
Everything's on fire
Loading bench
Hello
Ham radio, why they call it a ham radio? Is everybody okay in here? There's a lot of beds
A lot of beds
If I sleep will that heal my xp?
Oh, it does what the fuck
I should just tell me that before
Yep, I'm ready to kill horse
What puppies
Don't worry, I won't have you lashed to a cross like the rest of these degenerates
Oh, I want you to witness the fate of the town of nipton to memorize. I don't really care. I just got here
And then when you move on I want you to teach everyone you meet the lesson that kaisar's legion taught
kaisar is not scissors
kaisar
What what did you teach?
Okay, I don't really care
Can I just shoot him in the head there's too many witnesses that puppy is
Can I get a puppy? I want a puppy
I bet that's mods, right? Oh, that's too bad
Oh
Well, I was on my way doing something else. So I don't know if I'll have time to do what you said
Can I take a stop? Oh
Okay
Oh, he's still alive
I just wanted to steal your shit. Uh, can I have it?
I can put you out of your misery
If I shoot one of them will they be mad?
No, okay
Oh
You guys don't have anything I'm just helping you
I'm mercy killing
What the fuck I can't hit him I'm out of bullets
You're very lucky sir very lucky
I could have sworn I had millimeter bullets. What the fuck?
All right. Well
You're very lucky sir very lucky just kidding
Yippie I just want to kill people what's in here
Yung
That was a son of god for my first time doing what footlocker ooh bobby pin
A gecko steak
Oh if it blinks, I mean it's outside the building interesting
Bye
I'm just merciful
I'm just trying to help out the less fortunate
Wait, I should have gone into the big build what the fuck
Okay
Oh, I'll take that flamer fuel
Uh, okay
Oh
Oh, this is what I can make
What is that? I don't know what these mean
I can I take your ear why can I take your ear? Oh, that's a very weird thing that I can take
Oh
I
Crack your money from bounties. Oh, okay got you got you
Did they leave? Oh this guy's still alive
He's some crazy concealer under his eyes
Yippie
Cool, let me just loot your bodies
Someone shooting it's fine
No, nothing I probably already took all your shit, huh? There might be a safe in here
I can do ball cap with glasses
I
Hear puppies
Brom and skin outfit all like the leather
Let's do it. Oh
How do I
Why don't I suddenly remember okay, I was like
Yeah
What the fuck what the fuck
There we do hold on I'm looking
No puppy, I don't want to shoot you puppies. No
I'm so sorry
Hold on reloading puppy
Oh
You don't you don't have any bullets on you
Oh, I didn't want to kill puppies
I only have a few bullets
So vending machine
I
For accurate need yeah, brother
I hear another puppy
I don't have
Is there a puppy on the other side
Oh
Aren't you dead yet
I'm so sorry
No, don't show your dogs this why would you show your dogs this?
There's so many dogs here
Why do they just leave their dogs behind why can't I tame them?
There's a cat on my desk it is boomy
No safes I'm here to steal shit, bro
Boomy's looking my cereal bowl stop
I
Hear more puppies no
I'm out of hold on
I
That's great I have a messed up limb
Oh my god pup what the hell damn it I didn't save
There's a landmine oh
It saved when I came in the door
No
You're still alive
Stop
I don't care about vats it's um
What's that
Boomy what are you doing? I can't drink out of the the kitty bowl
The kitty bowl the cereal bowl. Where are you going?
Where are you? Why do you why is your mouth open?
Why is your tongue sticking out?
I'm kissing the kiss the baby boy
Boomy why don't you just hang out on my lap?
Are you purring?
Oh am I getting a little purr
Oh my goodness
Sorry, hold on
I
Was getting little rumbles boomy your pouches out and your nippies are poking
Oh, it's cat feeding time
All right, I just saved it. I don't know why I saved you
Um
I
What I thought it said I had help
I thought it said I have 25 bullets. Why does it say I have zero? Is that what the 25 means?
Am I
laser pistol
Oh, wait, no, it says zero zero everybody. I'm looking at the I can look can I can hold 25?
I'm in danger
Okay
No, I have to
I have to make my hat big
No, not myself big. I need to make my hat bigger
Oh, I need to make my hat bigger not myself bigger
Wait, did I have to do it three more times?
Did I miss either do the bigger hat times three?
Oh god
One two three, okay
Oh
Guys
I
Can't shut me if I can't see my eyes
I'm I'm shabby dimadone. I'm the dimsdale dimadone
Are you good? You can't even see the game
I'm gonna see if I can clear this place out and then I'll um um save and feed the baby
And feed for you
Oh
Why does it do that
I stole from lady Dimitrescu's wardrobe. I only have 11 shots left
Oh, no more puppies
It ran away
I don't have anything to attack you with
Oh
I lost my arm
It's fine
Oh
I forgot I had a super sim pack
I need to whap it I need like fucking
I don't have like any
I have two. Oh, okay. I can't ever got I forgot. I have this fucking thing. I'm so dumb
Thank you cause I did the super perfect
Wait, no, that's where I came from. Sorry
What in formation is good water. Oh, I can't drink from it. No, I'm I can't drink from the toilet
Very easy well
Can I have this telephone open the desk? Oh
It's funny that bottle caps are currency
Nothing in these stuff
Oh
Mayor's office there's gotta be a safe in the mayor's office. Come on now
I don't want to finance clipboard
Higher over
I I I don't care
Oh like that laser pistol
Sometimes I just don't see stuff
I
Broke force it no
Requires a key
It's fucking stupid
Are you serious bro?
Requires a key
As a boy water science on the desk
Oh science why is everything floating?
So now I need to get a key
No
Oh
Yeah
Uh
Science can't forget the science and forget the bobby pins
Anything else? All right, we won't force it this time
I
Cram
What's a brak so cleaner
Do I need that
I found these drugs
I
Can't get out hell
Gun cabinet. Oh my god
I don't know what that means plasma rifle. Thank you very much
Okay
Yeah, of course this one because it's a hundred percent
Empty empty empty empty empty empty empty
Empty empty this one our bottle caps
That's right
That's laser and plasma
I
Forgot the vending machine has stuff we just you don't have to buy it
You just take it you should do that more often. How do I get out of here?
Laser is pew pew plasma is pew pew
No
Oh
I'm so sorry
Um
There's so many dead puppies
What have I done did I go down here?
Oh, I did oh wait, but I can look at this
What a beautiful day where's my hat?
What do you mean where's my hat is it gone?
Is my head did my hat disappear?
Oh what the fuck it's still there. I thought so I thought vtube studio freaked out
Thank you motherfuckers because I can't I can't see vtube studio because of how the game is being
Why can't I say when my pit boy is out? I don't I don't like that
Okay, it is time to feed for you
I'm wondering if I should pause here. Let me see
What do you mean what happened to my hair
I might end it here
I feed the baby and then I have been streaming since like
10 30 a.m. Uh, I mean what no I haven't um
So I will
I I've been up for a bit. I've been streaming all day. So I think I'm gonna go rest
You want me to feed her on stream?
I
Might take too long
What right now did you say something what?
Speak your truth what?
What yeah
Yeah
Yep
Are you a lady?
She's squeaking at me
What I've turned away and then she jumped on my desk. Okay, ma'am. I was I'm trying to
Okay, she wants to hug. Ow. You just stepped on my nipple. That's fine
All right, I'm gonna go
um
Let's find someone to read
Jesus burn
Rain up her she just hopped into the microphone. That was kind of funny. Um
Um
Azura is streaming so I'm gonna raid her
Where'd she start? Okay, she started like only like 10 minutes ago. Um, she's playing Final Fantasy
So go have fun with boomy. What are you?
What are you doing, dude? Go have fun with Azura playing Final Fan
I'm fun nasty. Uh-huh final FNAF at Freddy's. Okay, Rena. I'm gonna put you on my desk for a second, please
Will you be okay? Will you be fine?
Rena don't drink out of that. Oh, there's like two cats on my desk stop
Okay, please I'm taking this bowl. I'm hiding it under my blanket. So none of you guys can get it
I
What the heck what happened to the stream I can't see the chat
Okay, I can see it again
Okay, bye, I'll see you
Cloudstripe the animatronic. I will see you guys tomorrow for my
Um, I'll probably stream earlier before my collab play some Elden Ring
And um
Yeah
Maybe I'm so addicted. I just like a game. I might not allowed to play a game
Shush
But uh, thank you for hanging out with me today
Elden week. Yeah, I think like I don't know if strong ear icy is playing it this week or next week. I remember
Oh, bye Mari
I almost I clicked edit video to end stream. That's how tired I am right now. Okay. Bye
Keep rooting to in this shooting and keep that booty put in
Like like pooping not like not like the Russian guy. I don't like that. Don't
Don't do that
Okay, bye. Go have fun with the Zura. You can say, um
Root and toot and raid. That's what it is
There you go
Okay, bye
Thank you. Bye